the january 6th committee is the
stupidest crackpot garbage i've ever
seen in my life these people are
despicable i view them all as uh
unrepentantly evil scumbags the
embodiment of everything wrong with
congress and our federal government and
they have released text messages from
trump's inner circle and i guess i don't
know what their point was but they just
basically disproved the whole
insurrection narrative they they
released text messages showing that
high-profile conservative personalities
donald trump jr himself tons of members
of congress were texting mark meadows
chief of staff at the time for donald
trump saying tell him to condemn this we
have to act it's bad shut it down
and then trump did speak out and condemn
it and they still got mad at him so if
the narrative is that trump was trying
to stage a conspiracy or insurrection
when quite literally all the evidence is
pointing to these people saying please
stop this they've accidentally disproved
their own stupid narrative but they're
still going for it because now they're
like yeah well laura ingram said this is
really bad for us and then claimed it
was antifa and it's like
yeah you can still claim a a riot is bad
for you or just bad in general and still
think there was anti for there at least
one of the guys who was there was
apparently some antifa affiliated guy
but i think the narrative that antifa
was leading the charge is just not
correct that being said their narrative
is stupid but we'll talk about that we
got a couple other big stories too
inflation is alarming to say the least
the producer price index i think it's
called is uh up nearly 10 so this is
like the cost of goods for wholesalers
this is the fastest growth on record
this is
i don't know i call it apocalyptic
because what we're hearing across the uh
you know over the the pacific is that
this could trigger a global economic
collapse not just this but also the fact
that consumer price index is massively
high food prices are higher than they've
been in decades
and there's no sign that's going to get
better and then we got to uh elon musk
he's currently tweeting at senator uh
warren insulting her it's really funny
and we'll talk about that too joining us
today is jordan shacktel how's it going
man you want to introduce yourself yeah
hey you can pull that mic up and
straighten it out that's good
moving around it just goes everywhere no
tim thanks so much for having me on i
don't know if anyone knows there's like
a mythology surrounding this place so
whenever a new guest enters we start to
talk to our buddies about what it was
like
and uh it's definitely living up to the
hype i saw i saw the skate park and
everything
yeah i'm uh i'm an independent
journalist i run the the dossier on
substack right now been doing it for
about a year it's going great um you
know my background's in foreign policy
but i've been covering covet mania for
now the next two years or so
and um there's some very interesting
developments that we're going to talk
about today and i really appreciate you
guys bringing me in cool man thanks for
coming wait until you find out about the
initiation rituals that are going to
happen afterwards well that's another
story hey guys
um i do believe it's very important to
take their own language and to use it
against them and that's why i created
this shirt that says freedom super
spreader which you could exclusively
exclusively get on
thebestpoliticos.com and because you do
i'm here so thanks for having me i'm
excited for this conversation what's up
everybody ian crossland over here happy
to be here ian crossan.net check it out
and i'm also here in the corner pushing
buttons which is my favorite job in the
world um i'm happy to be here with
jordan for who came up from florida
right yeah south florida about and
everybody's in florida in the miami
region i'm sorry to bring you up to our
our swan plan but i'm glad you're here i
live my miami six years for six years oh
yeah that's right we're in here is it
south florida literally swamp land
uh the everglades so if you go a little
west yeah it's a giant swamp filled with
yeah terrifying gators
too i live i lived right next to it i
lived in uh the redlands okay yeah for
about a year and miami's absolutely
amazing but the weather is just
apocalyptically bad perfect but we'll
get into all that stuff um we have a
sponsor but uh someone super chatted
about something very important so i'm
gonna read that first uh it's alex
how do you pronounce that magiore he
says you said last night you played
spelunky too have you made it to the
cosmic ocean yet
um
absolutely not that's crazy i i don't
even understand this game half the time
i i i don't play the game enough to
actually bother getting to the cosmic
ocean it's just it's insane you got to
do like 10 things in the game with like
but you can you get four health and you
you die once and then it's like the
whole game starts over so i'm just not
even going to bother with trying to get
to that and then that's like i think
it's what like 99 levels to be oh my
gosh really crazy it was hard it was
like watching a friend with like an
addict like a drug addiction beating
themselves like watching you play
spelunky too it was hard to watch no
wait dude
i can beat spelunky too like every time
you have a splunky one unlock and
splunky too yeah right i
i i got seated runs unlocked anyway oh
the point is the cosmic ocean is a level
above wherever i am in terms of playing
that game so that being said we've got a
sponsor tonight my friends you need to
get virtual shield it's a virtual
private network service go to
surfinginternetsafe.com
and you can get 50 off of all of their
tools their add-ons for life and the
actual product you'll get 24 months of
online security from the world's easiest
and fastest vpn for only 59.88 it's
about 250 per month let me explain
something to you guys why you should get
this
first of all virtual shield has
supported us from the very beginning
it's my first sponsor and you know you
definitely want to support companies
that that support us
a virtual private network helps keep
your data safe nothing is perfect but
there are prying eyes they're hackers
they're government agents they're
massive corporations they want to track
your data they want to spy on you if you
want a basic level of security while you
browse the web while you're searching
for things while you're sending emails
doing whatever you you should get you
should you should have a vpn and i'll
give you a really good example why right
now one of the stories we're going to
cover in just about a minute is that
people who are having their their text
messages leaked by the january 6
committee have are filing lawsuits
against these phone companies saying
stop giving out our text messages why is
it
that your private communications are
sitting in a server somewhere for some
company and you don't even know who's
reading them and then when some crackpot
in congress like adam schiff comes out
and he's like i would like to leak this
person's private information they go you
got a boss and they give it right to
them
adam schiff leaked an american
journalist's private information
this is why you want virtual private
network services you want and encryption
take this stuff seriously i'm not saying
anybody's coming after you i'm not
saying you'd be paranoid i'm just saying
keep that in mind go to
surfinginternetsafe.com
these guys virtual shield supports the
show and they support us from the
beginning so i have much respect for
them and i think it's a great service
also don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member and directly support our
work we launched a new show recently we
launched our first book it's available
on amazon
we're not big fans of amazon but tails
from the inverted world is now available
for purchase a paperback book on amazon
and we're going to ramp that up soon and
get more stuff rolling out with that but
you'll also get access to our members
only segments we'll have a members only
segment of tim casserole podcast up
around 11 or so pm all of this is
possible everything we do is only
possible because you guys sign up to
become members so i am deeply
appreciative for all of your support and
don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends and now let's get
into that first story
you know when i first saw this this
morning the story about them leaking
text messages i got really angry because
i am disgusted
by these establishment shills these
disgusting vile creatures of congress
they're they're they're cannibalistic
humanoid underground dwellers who have
lurched up from the underground crawled
into congress and we just sit back we're
like yeah i guess we'll keep voting for
these people but hopefully now people
are waking up and they will vote out all
of these people especially people like
liz cheney and the story from the
independent donald trump jr sent
desperate texts to mark meadows during
capital right urging trump to take
action he has to lead now revelation of
texts come as committee votes to support
contempt of congress charge for former
chief of staff
did i say these people are absolutely
vile and disgusting because i'll just
keep saying it now
that being said the release of these
texts donald trump jr was urging mark
meadows to get his dad to condemn the
riot at the capitol
sounds like they did not want it to
happen sounds like all of these people
in trump's inner circle were like yo
stop this
and then trump came out and issued a
statement saying that it was wrong and
to go home go home peacefully
so they just effectively debunked their
whole narrative if that's the case why
should any of this continue
total clown show i mean in a moral
civilization a moral america
liz cheney would be shunned from society
i see her picture on the screen there
as a foreign policy guy i can tell you
all the all the wars she supported all
the military armament uh for the
military industrial complex for for all
of these special interests liz cheney
has the worst of the worst record and
the idea that she's like playing along
it shows that there's really there's two
parties in america there's the unit
party represented by liz cheney um she
is a member in good standing
unfortunately most of the establishment
republicans and people in charge are
also part of that unit party and then
you have nancy pelosi and this january 6
committee is utterly utterly ridiculous
and the fact that she's like supposed to
be like the republican side making it
authentic it's absurd they're like
bipartisan support for you know uh
contempt of congress or whatever
the text messages don't really prove an
insurrection more but everyone kind of
panicking be like this is bad this is
bad this is bad so it's just absurd to
see them still complaining because this
obviously disproves everything that they
were talking about they claimed that
this was orchestrated this was all
planned they tried to take
obviously through the text messages this
is not true we're also learning today
that a dc that the dc attorney general
is going to be is going to be suing the
proud boys and oath keepers because of
the january 6th attack so to me this is
all about just the total dominance of
political power in the establishment to
keep it with themselves and to make sure
that of course trump doesn't have any
political power going forward in the
next election there's also going to be
local elections and i think they're just
kind of fishing for whatever they could
get so they could hit the other side the
other side isn't just as as good again
it's all about power it's all about
authority and they're trying to
consolidate as much of it as they can
and it's absolutely authoritarian than
it is investigative at all if we're
gonna investigate somebody why not get
the text messages of you know mr epstein
or gelane maxwell let's release that to
the general public or the videos or the
footage that the fbi is holding to
themselves i would want to know that i
don't care what these people are doing
freaking out you know the worst i think
the worst person in in in congress
probably is probably mitch mcconnell
absolutely and then um the reason i say
that over like nancy pelosi or whatever
it's like nancy pelosi's overt you know
what is it saying the better the devil
you know yep like when nancy pelosi
comes out and she's like oh and her
teeth are falling out and she rips up
trump's speech i'm like i can see the
disdain i can see the the vile behavior
mitch mcconnell just like sticks his
head in his shell and then does nothing
but people vote for him and then you
expect to get some kind of resistance
what the democrats are doing but he's
effectively standing in the way of
regular americans as the democrats you
know go and do their their crackpot
garbage i think the i don't remember who
said this but they said that
the the the republicans are the
washington generals to the democrats
harlem globetrotters absolutely and it's
all faked it's all rigged it's all like
world wrestling entertainment i tweeted
a photo today of mitch mcconnell elbow
bumping nancy pelosi
and the caption read if uh effing the
poor people was a handshake this would
be it and that's absolutely what they're
doing they're screwing over hard-working
average americans who are just trying to
live their lives and they're they're
playing this theater this show to try to
convince you that the other side is the
lesser of two evils meanwhile they're
working together in collusion they're
two heads of the same snake and they are
a den of vipers they are sinister
reptilian-like beings that are
cold-blooded and don't give a damn about
you or your friends or your family or
the future of this country they are
selling this country to the highest
bidder and if you are getting screwed
that's all figurative of course do you
think it's the people or the positions
that turn the people into those things i
think it's a combination of both and it
also depends on the individual for for
example henry kissinger i think he's a
corrupt personal sociopathic crazy
person that just thrives off of creating
policies that create human misery for
the benefit of his friends that's my
personal perspective and opinion other
people i believe were entangled in the
system came into the system and they
were told fix the system from the inside
make it better you could fix it just by
being a part of it but you just have to
sell out on this small issue and then
this small issue and then this small
issue and then they get them hanging out
with mr epstein they get the videotapes
of them and then bada bing bada boom
they got them in their pockets a part of
the larger extortion operation and now
they're coming to them saying hey we
need this unpopular bill passed that's
going to screw over your constituency
you're going to have to pass it or we're
going to release the dirt that we have
on you and that's essentially washington
d.c politics that we're seeing unfold
right now and a part of why so many
unpopular uh policies get passed that's
one example of it the other is just
sociopathic individuals the most amount
of sociopaths are located per capita in
washington dc for a specific reason
what's that part of the brain where they
say that sociopaths have like an
underdeveloped or small amygdala
i wonder if we could do like is there
like a like a
cat scan or an mri you can do on like
members of congress to make sure and be
like hey look at that they're all psycho
and drug test them i want drug tests on
all members of congress all right i want
term limits i want all the restrictions
they put on the general public put on
them but who votes on that that's the
problem is that they need to vote for
restrictions on themselves yes yeah
they're not going to do it
you know you know it's like this would
actually be like a great sketch it's
like you get some principled politician
maybe like a rand paul or something and
he's like i've got a new bill that says
you know we're we're all going to have
to undergo drug testing and anything we
pass the american people and then you'll
get like a bunch of politicians big that
sounds really really good and uh so
we're gonna vote on this bill rand paul
it's a bill to give us a raise thanks
rand paul for your time uh all in favor
of giving us a raise and they'll raise
their hands
and then rand is just sitting there
going like oh well some people argue
that they should be given a raise so
they won't be tools for the
multinational corporations that buy them
out i think you know the best example i
think george carlin was the one
advocating for this put advertisements
on their suits for whoever endorses them
and gives them money which they have to
wear everywhere they go i think it's
more it's a funny idea but these
companies will be like they'll have
dinner with the guy and be like look you
know here's a here's a 100 plate you
know on k street i hope you enjoy the
steak we need you to pass this bill
because it's going to be really great
for the production of our thing you know
our our product and then um maybe uh
half a half a million dollars might find
its way towards your super pack exactly
that's even easier you could just have
you can have a lobbyist go and meet with
nancy pelosi somehow she ends up worth
hundreds of millions of dollars on a
congressional salary congress is allowed
to inside trade as long as there's like
a little bit of room between them and
their broker i mean the system that's
set up is utterly absurd they're abusing
it it's just
it's so ridiculous it's such a farce
they're all taking part of it um i don't
know if you saw there's a news report
today that all of these uh congressmen
and senators are trading inside
information on pharmaceutical companies
and they're just like kind of allowed to
do it for some reason because they're
again they're the ones that make the
rules so they're never gonna impose a
limit on themselves unless there's like
a giant national movement that says
enough is enough i got it
i got it
you know i'm thinking about how what
would ron paul do and he's always
talking about competition i say we
create a new a second congress to
compete with the other congress and they
pass rules on each other maybe another
another country to compete with this
we need more competition in this country
but the only way that would work is if
there was free movement between the
other country and people could choose to
live there instead which is actually
true for a lot of countries and nobody
wants to go live there so organized
competition you know americans i mean
you can move to a lot of places and
they'll welcome you and you don't got to
do anything you just live there i know
people who just moved to mexico and
mexico is like awesome yeah great yeah
and there's a lot of expats all over
latin america who are taking advantage
of a lot of freedoms that they're
granted and also a lot of health care
that usually is a lot better and a lot
cheaper than it is here in the united
states especially in major urban areas
so there is a huge movement of expats
people expatriating even to puerto rico
because of the
tax liability that they're able to get
away with down in puerto rico rather
than of course uh in the united states
so there's there's been a huge movement
of this and i i think
it's it's only going to be kind of
exacerbated especially with countries
like mexico saying hey this this mandate
stuff is absolute nonsense we don't
believe in punishing our population we
don't believe in locking down our
population we believe in actually doing
the right thing and i think that mexico
has has really had a kind of
clear-headed approach towards this
madness that we're dealing with but but
back to this kind of hyper politization
january 6th committee meeting this is a
sign of just again the political parties
at odds with each other using dirty
tricks abusing authority because the
democrats as we talked about on the show
before their literal stance on
everything is like hey we're not donald
trump that's not a stance that's not
helping anyone that's not doing anything
that's them complaining about somebody
it's not democrat republican it's like
you were saying jordan unit party versus
like populist i guess statist versus
people who believe in freedom and i
think there's a whole bunch of statists
and i think that should be the true kind
of political spectrum that we should be
dealing with and talking about rather
than left and right but one of the
issues i suppose is that the
progressives are typically like like the
populist left in this country aligns
themselves more with the uniparty
so with the with the republicans you
have you got some crazy republicans you
got some weirdos but the right-wing
populists dominate the republican party
right now the left-wing populists are on
the ground begging for scraps and so
what they do is they you know they beg
hillary clinton for the endorsement they
beg joe biden and then joe biden's like
i'm gonna i'm gonna forgive student loan
debt if you vote for me and then all the
leftists and all the progressives are
like yes vote for biden then biden's
like
you you dumbass i'm not forgiving
anything yeah and now the latest news is
joe biden says he's not gonna forgive
any like and we we we try to tell these
young people
idealistic starry-eyed joe biden is not
the man you think he is but they vote
for him anyway they support the
establishment they like to to defend
massive multinational corporations and
then act like they're the progressives i
got to tell you this the weirdest thing
to me is that
all of us here i'm assuming you jordan i
don't know your politics on free speech
and stuff but i think we're all to the
left of hassan [ __ ] and vosh when it
comes to social media and big tech and
corporate influences which brings me to
that story specifically
we have this story
from teamcast.com popular twitch
streamers hassan [ __ ] and vosh banned
from platform for racism against white
people literally now i'm actually going
to um i've got some criticism for first
i've got criticism for hassan absolutely
but i've got criticism and some defense
for vosh
vosh
i don't think cared at all overtly
stated he was going to say the racial
slur laughed got banned and laughed
again
so my attitude towards vosh is if you
publicly say
these companies are private companies
they can ban whoever they want and if
you use a slur you'll get banned and
then you literally go on the channel
laughing saying you're gonna do it i'm
like yeah i respect it like you're just
trolling you like he knew he's gonna get
banned it's not hypocritical i just
think he shouldn't be saying the racial
slurs and i think he has bad ideas on
you know massive multinational
corporations but i'm not i'm not going
to say it's hypocritical for him to be
laughing about it now hassan
is the guy who actually puts out videos
where he says that people on the right
should follow the rules and they just
want to make their own right-wing echo
chamber and own the libs but because
they break the rules they get banned
well he literally went on his channel
and said that he's allowed to say racial
slurs particularly if they're against
white people and now he's gotten a ban
for it the important thing here is
twitch bans are not bans they're like
they'll reinstate you at some point so
they don't call it suspension or
whatever it's the weirdest thing they're
like i got banned for this and then
but they reinstate you tomorrow it's not
really a ban yeah they're going to be
back i think in in a very short time
especially with their user base whatever
they have saying hey please get these
people back on this platform but
i i still don't understand why people
have to describe other people as salty
delicious snacks i i don't i don't get
it what is that reference to um oh oh oh
oh
delicious
luke's a big fan of cracker barrels his
favorite restaurant i absolutely love
greg
so um anyway i think you know what word
was used and uh no i'm pretty sure on
youtube you're allowed to say cracker
and and karen and all that stuff because
uh
youtube agrees with hassan in the
context twitch apparently doesn't which
is weird now i will say though i don't
think you can call someone a cracker
what happened was i think hassan
directly said you are an effing be a you
know there you go in general you want to
avoid calling people names yeah on
social media that's that draws the ire
of admins yeah if it's a nice word if
you use it as a name-calling tactic
here's here's the craziest thing to me
when it comes to the idea of left or
right in terms of the economic sense
vosh and hassan and and and i normally
don't like to talk about like other you
know internet personalities but this is
relevant towards the the conversation of
the commons and these are two of some
like these are two of the biggest
commentators on the internet hassan i
believe is the biggest in the on the
left how is it that we here at tim cast
irl are to the left of them when it
comes to this particular issue i'm not
going to pretend we're to the left of
them on a bunch of issues relating to
businesses
but
we are to the left or at least in the
lower quadrant towards libertarian yeah
i think when it comes to social media
this is more about authoritarianism and
libertarianism statism versus freed
freedom more so than it is about left
versus right
where i fall
relative to hassan and them i don't know
but i think i'm definitely
on the libertarian aspect but this is
the reason why i say we're to the left
even luke is to the left of them on this
issue is that what we're talking about
is private corporate power
taking over the commons twitter facebook
youtube etc have seized the the spaces
in which we communicate and started
exerting their will to force politics in
a certain direction that is not
government that is not state that is
private power that has built up enough
of it to seize the commons
now i'm pretty sure luke you're opposed
to censorship on these platforms
absolutely and especially the collusion
that a lot of these big tech companies
including amazon have with the pentagon
have with the cia and how much they work
hand in hand together which makes them
not a private entity but a quasi-state
private entity that of course colludes
together for the personal benefit of the
ruling elites and creates billionaires
that have way too much power way too
much control only because of the
government allowing them to have this so
i wouldn't even argue
yeah absolutely fascistic i wouldn't
even argue that i'm on the left again
the spectrum is either your status or
you believe in freedom i believe in
absolute freedom stop stop having
multinational corporations colluding
with jeff bezos with amazon with with
prime with twitch and all that it's just
too much government interference too
much uh policy directed in the benefit
of them that's screwing everyone else
over giving an unfair advantage to to
regular competitors to an extent but gab
mines rumble odyssey all these platforms
exist the issue is they have monopoly
power exactly well if you look at a lot
of the infrastructure that facebook that
google that amazon have built they have
built it on u.s tax paying dollars that
of course incentivized and worked with
the intelligence agencies and a lot of
other people within the pentagon that
helped them have an unfair advantage on
everyone else so when you look at the
collusion that's been happening i would
argue that it is absolutely not a
private enterprise it is an enterprise
that of course has its benefits and just
like it hit people on the right it's
eventually going to hit people on the
left because censorship of course knows
no bounds eventually it has in this
instant but they're going to get their
channel back but later down the line i
think this larger kind of censorship
stick that hit the right predominantly
more than the left is eventually going
to wipe anyone else who has even a
smidget of anti-establishment within
them smidget yeah smidget like a little
smidgen like a smidget
that's a word right
i'm curious as to what your stance is on
uh
i i radically err on the side of
individualism and free markets but i do
understand how difficult it is if you're
looking at google which may have a 100
year monopoly on on the search engine
before anyone really you know competes
with them so we're talking about an
issue that could take the course of our
lifetimes to correct so is but what kind
of action do we want to see on that
front do we want our corrupt mitch
mcconnell kevin mccarthy chuck schumer
nancy pelosi
coalition do we want them to deal with
it or do we want individuals to deal
with it somehow uh and obviously there's
no perfect answer to this because we
would have had a solution already and as
tim said you know there's rumble there's
all these other the startup sites uh
donald trump's getting in the mix with
the social media site we'll see what
happens but i think google
it uncontested has the biggest monopoly
and they are the biggest threat uh as
opposed to like you know facebook maybe
who knows what kind of staying power
they have twitter they might
self-immolate at this point with their
you know woke ceo and the social justice
warriors that run the site but i think
google has a very serious monopoly they
not only have a monopoly on on the
search but they have a monopoly over our
minds essentially because it's so 99
point whatever percent of the population
still uses google you're getting all of
your results from google google is like
a state as luke said is basically like a
state enterprise at this point and it is
a very much a threat to our civilization
for the the the fans of vash and hassan
who may end up watching this or maybe
watching it i'll give you a very simple
explanation for um the issue with
control of the commons
so
would you would you agree
that conservatives
don't want to use preferred pronouns i
think the answer most people regardless
of left right would say well of course
conservatives don't want to use
someone's preferred pronouns
so on twitter for instance and many
other platforms they enforce the use of
these pronouns
now if you're on the left you may agree
with that i'm not telling you you're not
allowed to feel that way by all means
you can have that opinion okay i respect
you having your right to your opinion
the issue then becomes if that is
clearly and discernibly a left wing
position and the right is at odds with
it the rules on twitter directly and
negatively impact the right and not the
left that is a rule on the platform dead
naming is man
this is
overt now you can say and what the left
early says is tim's arguing in favor of
transphobia or whatever i never said
that i'm saying just understand if you
know conservatives say i don't want to
use your pronouns then the rules favor
the left ergo you are in a left-wing
echo chamber where big tech firms are
controlling the narrative and forcing it
in a certain direction now of course for
many on the left they're like well
that's good because they're pushing my
ideas great by all means feel that way
but now don't deny that the rules are
absolutely set up to to be a negative to
be detrimental to the right
probably because the people who run
these companies agree with you on those
opinions well when you've got you know
80 or so million people in this country
who don't agree with that then i think
it's fair to say we have a very serious
problem now you know hassan has done uh
one of the things one of the videos i
watched from him uh recently
was him talking about the right doesn't
want to use conservative platforms
because they want to own the libs and
what they don't understand what hassan
needs to understand is it's not about
owning the libs because obviously hassan
you do content where you own the cons i
mean that's a common thing regardless of
your political faction it's the issue
that twitter owns the commons they own
it their parlor doesn't have nearly
enough people to even talk to to debate
to question to to engage with the same
is true for rumble the same is true for
minds these are these are platforms you
know good for them getter i mean it's
great they exist but people want to be
in the comments they want to walk up to
their neighbor and say i humbly disagree
and some of them want to screech well we
don't like it when people screech but
how are you even supposed to debate the
idea of misgendering if you get banned
before you can even say it so imagine if
you went to the town square and the
mayor was using the police force to beat
you and kick you out because you said
black lives matter and that happens too
and it's wrong
the rules are absolutely slanted and
that's a problem
we're also being ruled by algorithms
algorithms that can't really figure out
discernment so whenever you say
something that's on google's no talk
list they will hit you no matter what
the context and a lot of individuals do
get hit especially smaller channels
smaller individuals with less
subscribers who of course are trying to
legitimately talk about an issue but
because of of youtube stigmatization
they can't there's so many history
channels on youtube that got nuked that
got utterly destroyed for simply just
talking about history and a perspective
that is important to understand but you
can't on youtube because of the
algorithm because of ai deciding if
you're going to have a voice in our
current society and that to me is
absolutely ridiculous and when the left
was celebrating this kind of political
censorship cheering it on i said it's
only a matter of time until they get you
i think we're reaching that kind of
major bridge that it's affecting them
and i think it's only going to affect
them more just like antifa they use
antifa the state knows everything that
antifa does they know all the
individuals are part of their
institutions the intelligence agencies
have a database of all their names
they're going to use them but after
they're they're done taking out the
people on the right that's the next
people that are going to go after let me
just stress
when it comes to the january 6 committee
they just got the text messages from how
many people members of congress
mainstream media journalists donald
trump jr journalists they just went to
the phone companies and said we'd like
their their private communications and
they went you got it boss and then they
released it to the public amazing now
somebody chatted us
have we ever had michael malus and
vashon at the same time
that sounds like a good idea yeah it
does i don't know if you guys vosher or
michael you'd want to be down for
something like that but you know i was
like i don't want to keep just having
the same people on but that actually
does sound like a fun show yeah i wonder
you know because because michael's just
like overtly anarchist and vashta is a
libertarian socialist so i think there'd
be a really interesting conversation
there that'd be fun well you heard it
here we'll we'll reach out and see what
people are up to well let's talk about
some um some america
so that's that's where we went there and
now we're just doing a hard segue right
to this story from cnbc wholesale price
measure rose 9.6 in november from a year
ago the fastest pace on record the pace
was even faster than the estimate 9.2
the core producer price in index
increased at a 6.9 pace a bit slower
than estimates but still the fastest
ever in records dating in august 2014.
of course we also have uh news i think
they bring this up here that um for the
consumer price index as well it's also
massively up so basically long story
short inflation is through the roof the
m1 money supply uh so this is what i did
on my main channel today i pulled up the
m1 money supply
from march of 1986 when i was born
until today
from the from the day month of my birth
until the 2008 crisis the money supply
just narrowly doubled
from 800 billion to 1.6 trillion
from
that point forward we get to the
pandemic year where the money supply due
to how they track the money the savings
accounts they said now savings are
effectively checking the money supply
increased i think like five like five
times
from something like two trillion to like
16 trillion that's not two times like
eight times but i could be wrong i think
it was i think no i'm sorry five times
and i think it might have been three but
since then since may of 2020
we have added i think something like
four or five trillion dollars to the
money supply and now the democrats are
proposing printing another i'm sorry
raisin that's selling another 2.5
trillion joe biden puts out that video
where he's like we pay our debts in
america that's why i'm raising the debt
ceiling and it's like that's not paying
your debts that's taking out a credit
card to pay off loans it doesn't work
eventually your the debts come due and
you default
so i'll tell you this very simply put
what we are seeing now with this
wholesale price increase
it's like watching the initial tsunami
start coming in the water starts pouring
over the seawall the pandemic was when
the water line receded and all the water
went away and we're like where'd the
water go now all that water is rushing
back faster and higher than ever
and we're seeing these these signs i
have a feeling that next year is going
to be apocalyptic apocalyptically bad
and i wonder if we're entering like
weimar germany era like back in the day
during in the weimar era they were
shoveling bills like in the gutter it
was so worthless like venezuela levels
yeah in the fiat currency era in college
they tell you about keynesian
keynesianism about modern monetary
theory all this nonsense to kind of
cloud your brain but it's as simple as
what tim discussed a second ago is that
if you print a lot of money the money is
going to be worth less if you print
trillions of dollars there's trillions
of more dollars in circulation and that
means your purchasing power is
drastically reduced that cpi index is
actually based on a basket of goods that
isn't really
like there's other stuff in there that
can make it way higher and if you were
to calculate it
from the 80s consumer price index it
would be
almost 20 at this point inflation so
that that's the kind of numbers that
we're talking about and the idea that
like oh this is america so we're never
going to see hyperinflation that's kind
of
a dangerous
hedge to make especially because we've
only been on fiat currency for 50 years
so you know it's already these these
hyperinflation incidents has happened i
think in 60 countries now since then so
the idea that it can't happen in america
is a little foolish and you even have
jack dorsey you have twitter uh openly
mocking the idea that it's transitory
yeah yep
jack dorsey tweets in quotes transitory
yeah take a look at this from the m1
money supply
so a lot of people like to point out
that this major spike is a change in
reporting and we shouldn't really talk
about it which is bs
it used to be that you could only
transfer out of your savings account six
times to your checking account which
meant savings were meant to be saved
well because of the pandemic they said
spend away spend whatever you want to
the money supply immediately exploded
look at this
from 4 trillion 4.7 trillion up to 16.2
trillion
however let's ignore that metric and
let's talk about the current rate of
growth in the united states
from may of 2020 we were at 16.2
trillion today we're at 20 trillion in
october
look how much that's grown over nearly
four oh just about four trillion dollars
in close to what like a year and a half
now take a look at when the month the
month i was born march 1986
633 billion
how long did it take for that to double
really it was let's see where we go what
we're trying we're trying but it's going
down it's going up it's going down and
there we go
2003 from 1986 2003
to go up 600 billion dollars
now we're up trillions of dollars
already in the span of a year and a half
look at the percentages so in a year and
a half it went up 25
basically so we've and now go back to
the date of your birth how long did it
take to get 25 to 900 up there from
wherever it was
six years six years six years so it took
us one year now a year and a half to go
up a quarter that was like 30 years ago
but you got to understand too i don't i
don't think it makes sense to go
percentage once a month i don't think it
makes sense to go percentage-wise
because as as
the money supply from 16 trillion it's
happening too fast so it's going to be
exponentially bad right the the the
effects of the mass printing of money
the trillions of dollars in spending we
are not going to feel we're not going to
feel that immediately it's going to take
time yeah so what i what i imagine is
likely going to happen is you see that
chart showing inflation there's a major
spike where it's like up to seven
percent and now the presumer producer
pricing index is up you know 10
what are we going to hit max kaiser said
we were at 15 inflation and they're
lying yeah so that means what are they
going to officially start reporting 15
by mid next year
i mean it's going to be the apocalypse
for the democratic party it might just
be that one day you know 10 years down
the line will wake up and just realize
that our purchasing power is basically
worthless under the dollar i think that
a lot of people have this image in their
heads of one day we're just going to be
weimar germany and we're going to be
shoveling stuff in wheelbarrows and
maybe that day will come but inflation
kind of like it seems to be creeping up
on us you know if it's 10 compounding 10
10 10
then your purchasing power has been
significantly reduced over five years
and i think that's the thing that a lot
of people don't see coming is this
creeping inflation you do see the prices
rising but the prices will continue to
rise your purchasing power will go slow
slowly slowly deteriorating and that's i
think the big issue right now is that
slow road to a useless dollar yeah well
financially we have to understand the
trends usually correlate with the
actions weeks and months from those
actions so what happens now is going to
correlate in the market in a few months
from now and that's why in the beginning
of covet i said hey the the major factor
here that's really going to hurt people
is going to be financial keep an eye on
the financial markets it's absolutely
crazy what's happening right now the u.s
national debt has just crossed over 29
trillion dollars and i believe tucker
carlson had a very good talking point
just a few days ago he said young people
don't have any possibility to have any
economic opportunity no opportunity for
any kind of mobility finding mobility
financially and that's why people are
going over to bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and i think we are
seeing a transition for a lot of people
not trusting the financial markets
because how can you they're not playing
by any roles they're not playing by by
the math rules that are designed to that
specific
understanding of how
things work they're creating their own
rules they're just pressing zero on a
computer and giving it to their friends
meanwhile those zeros are having a real
life impact for everyone's purchases
every time you go to the supermarket you
see it you feel it and the average
person is having a harder and harder
time making ends meet and it's only
going to get worse from here from my
perspective the difference between what
we have and what weimar germany had is
it they were burning dollars or deutsche
marks i think it was in wheelbarrows we
don't even have paper anymore it's all
digital so like if our currency goes
belly up we don't even have paper to
burn or cotton to burn
at least they had toilet paper yeah at
least the venezuelans dry off well if
you're cold outside and you've got you
know blankets of
carbon fuel of some sort yeah you can
keep yourself warm we just got a number
on a screen that you know doesn't do
anything for us i think that this
suppressing suppression this economic
suppression is driving people to
extremism in so many ways one of it is
is cryptocurrency it's an extreme
evolution of currency the other is
antifa this extreme street violence
people feeling
uh disincentive disincentivized or
whatever disenfranchised it's the right
word
so and they're they're they're lashing
out in different ways some people are
intelligently evolving the economy some
people are just smashing stuff up it
seems like it's all relative i really
think we reached a point where this kind
of financial calamity this kind of
destruction of our economic system is
almost done deliberately because if you
look at every action the government is
taking it's making it that much worse on
everyone else how can else how else
could you explain giving the the
military-industrial complex a 20 billion
dollar bonus when they didn't even ask
for it how can you explain just the
reckless spending how can you explain
the build back better bill how can you
explain raising taxes on everyone else
is just absolutely absurd to see
people's savings people's hard-earned
money that they worked their entire
lives for literally be eviscerated right
in front of them it's crazy but here's
the good news so tucker carlson talked
about how
um people millennials
jenna even gen x gen z whatever the new
generation is that they're investing in
bitcoin because there's no ability to
save investing is very difficult um to
trade and stay up to par with inflation
but the good news about bitcoin is that
it is a clearly superior currency in my
opinion the fact that bitcoin has been
discovered gives people that exit route
so you don't need to be beholden to a
two and a half trillion dollar debt
ceiling increase you can
save in bitcoin and bitcoin is a finite
asset it's free market money uh the most
sound money ever invented i think its
properties are completely superior to
gold's in every sense you can debate
gold versus bitcoin and bitcoin beats it
in every single way so i think to add to
tucker's statement about people aren't
just
uh yes people are desperate to find a
way to hold on to their hard-earned
wealth but bitcoin also provides them an
exit and an actual superior currency to
the us dollar itself so that to me
that's the optimistic message is that
bitcoin can be a a protective off-ramp
to the chaos that's being caused by
these politicians and bureaucrats in
washington dc who don't have any of our
interests so let's let's jump to this
story real quick from the verge
nike just bought a virtual shoe company
that makes nfts and sneakers for the
metaverse now why do i bring up
metaverse in this context we're talking
about finance and inflation and prices
my friends hear me now the metaverse is
going to happen maybe not mark
zuckerberg's but there will be a
metaverse and it's already happening
apparently apparent uh a couple just
gotten married in the metaverse
cryptocurrency will likely be the
currency and tracking mechanism by which
you own
to us whatever to whatever extent you
can own a digital piece of property now
when they say you'll own nothing and
you'll be happy
in that world economic forum video or
that article they're talking about
physical objects but i i genuinely
believe the singularity will happen i
believe that uh bitcoin is is is going
to be a currency for this new digital
world nfts are going to be how you own
unique objects in this in this new
virtual reality and this is where
everyone is being pushed towards with
the collapse of the us economy and the
crisis we're seeing more and more people
are being told why don't you get
cryptocurrencies i mean we advocate for
the stuff we don't tell you any advice
but we love we you know i'm i'm a big
advocate for it but let's be real
a universal glo a a global digital
trackable
monetary system there's a lot of things
bad about that idea you'll be able to
see how who has how much money publicly
see how much money a person has when
they spend it and where it goes now of
course there is what z cash and monero i
believe make it much much more difficult
so other cryptos will emerge but here's
what i see with all of this you're not
going to get mark zuckerberg nuking
other companies and stealing a name if
he wasn't dead set on doing it you
wouldn't see nike buying a company that
makes virtual shoes
you wouldn't see this big push
while we are all discussing and debating
things like january 6 and anti-fun
street violence i think the real
push from the elites what they really
want is to get everybody in some kind of
metaverse some kind of digital
internet-based reality where they're
more easily controlled where they're
less likely to produce i'm sorry pollute
or fight there'll be less conflict
conflict will be digital and it's going
to be like that episode of black mirror
that's that's it's the inner universe
we're heading towards and this i think
shows it's happening so i've been
talking about bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies for a very long time
and i remember interviewing max kaiser
back in the early 2010s when bitcoin was
first hitting the world stage and i was
like in in london uh and i was talking
to max was walking with him i was like
how do we know that bitcoin isn't the
one world global government currency
that they've been waiting to push on to
everyone where they could track trace
and database everyone on the public
ledger and know everything that everyone
is doing and um i forgot max keiser's
response i got to watch my old videos in
order to see that but whether it's
bitcoin or another government coin we
know russia is working on their own kind
of cryptocurrency so is venezuela where
of course there'll be less protections
for personal freedoms and liberties
right now if you have a bitcoin address
it's as private as as much as uh anyone
else who knows about it so if no one
knows that i have a bitcoin address
there could be money coming out in and
out no one would would know it unless i
publicly tell someone i have a bitcoin
so it might be bitcoin it might be
another currency but there are other
people using this technology to push
privacy coins push for people to have
total anonymity online total freedom
total privacy and it's it's a
double-edged sword i think
cryptocurrencies it's the new internet
and i think just like it could be used
for something really bad and really evil
and and total government control i think
it could also be used for something that
could free people liberate people and
give them privacy which is absolutely
essential in our modern day society i
think it it i think it's great i think
bitcoin's fantastic but i do think it's
going to be an excellent tool
cryptocurrencies the blockchain in the
upcoming metaverse the digital world so
whether intentional or not it's
happening let's let's pull up this story
real quick and we'll add to the
conversation florida couple holds
virtual wedding in the metaverse while
simultaneously getting married in real
life complete with avatars that mimic
their exact moves for their online
guests
it's not that crazy an idea i think
people look at this and they don't
understand the context there's a lot of
people who couldn't travel to be at the
wedding so they did a virtual version so
you can put on your oculus or whatever
and watch it happen
i don't think virtual reality in the
metaverse is all bad i just think that
there are creepy elites who want to take
away your possessions and your ability
to work and make money and stick you in
a box where you have no kids and then
you rot and suffer and there's a lot of
really bad things about the elites want
technology is not all bad though however
i do think we are advancing in a creepy
direction and this may actually just be
a fad
i do believe we are more likely to be
heading into a metaverse singularity
type reality where we're brainchipped by
elon musk in the next year that's what
he's saying he's saying next year the
chips are going to be available to put
in people and and do all this stuff and
i do think there's going to be a big
push for this but we also heard what 12
years ago or 14 years ago that verachip
people are going to be getting chips and
planted in their hands and that never
really took off now we did see in sweden
people are getting the chip chips
implanted in their skin under their skin
that contains their covet information
and they walk up to doors and they can
stand it but that's the same thing we
saw 14 years ago it just did not happen
people were not interested in it now is
that going to be the same thing with the
metaverse that it's this big fad mark
zuckerberg dumps all this money and
effort into it and then everyone says yo
we don't want to do your stupid virtual
reality thing or are we forced into it
but i would i i'll just quickly say that
we don't have a microchip in our hand
but we have a phone in our hands almost
everywhere we go and some people say
that the microchip was replaced by the
phone which essentially almost acts like
the same thing another thing i would
just want to quickly add before going to
you ian is that the metaverse is an
excuse to put people into the smart
grids in major cities and into the
social credit scores that's how i see it
from a lot of the elitist perspectives
on what they want to achieve with it
sorry ian go ahead um
oh the difference i think uh between
what was what were we talking about
chipping your hand yeah is that the body
people don't like inserting things
inside themselves if they can that's not
true ian well they don't i don't
most people don't would opt to put on
the hat instead of inject the needle
into their into their temple yeah um i
know what you meant i was just making an
adult joke
oh tim
i'm gonna have to i didn't want to go
there i hadn't really had a comment
lined up but i was like okay like
whereas the body can reject things that
you insert into it um
whereas the metaverse is just more of
like a a spiritual
technological evolution bro have you
guys played with the oculus a little bit
not yet there's a game called like
pirate space robot or something space
pirate trainer it's so good dude it's so
good man i love it it's crazy so that
was holding the oculus or or the vr back
for a while right was that the
technology wasn't that good and now it's
good you're saying it's been good for a
few years yes
that's big it's it's it's yes it's
wireless it uses like ir tracking and so
uh to ian's point yeah i think you're
correct in that regard there's um
did you know that you can give yourself
an additional sense yeah now it's not
people say there's five senses or
whatever that's not true humans have way
more than five senses like people don't
count a sense of balance sense of
temperature but you can actually take
neodymium magnets and implant them under
your fingertips and then give yourself
electro perception or electrosense so
what happens is the magnets will be in
your finger
and i've i personally know people who
have done this
and when you move your hand past a a
power cable in a wall front so let's say
let's say there's a wall and trying to
find out where the cable is if you have
an embedded neodymium magnet in your
finger you can feel the electric fields
in your fingertips giving yourself
electrosense by doing this the problem
is the body rejects the magnet after a
certain amount of time it it breaks and
your body pushes it out through your
skin and it falls out yeah i heard a lot
of stories about dogs that were
microchipped getting uh you know
infections and diseases and cancers
near wherever they had the microchip
injected those are some of the stories
that i saw on the internet even just a
few years ago so it wouldn't surprise me
if they transitioned from you know let's
inject it to let's just have them uh
have it everywhere they go including
when they go poop then how is elon musk
going to implant the computer chips did
they figure this out
have you seen have you seen the neural
link stuff the monkey yeah very surgery
very thin copper wires that make contact
so maybe that is too small to get
rejected maybe it just sits you know
thread them into like the outer layer of
the brain they like carve out like a a
quarter-sized hole in the skull and then
they thread like i don't know a thousand
tiny little fibers into like the
the top layer of the brain and then the
that gives the impulses ideally they're
gonna evolve it so that they don't have
to cut the the scalp the skull open or
insert anything some people are saying
they're going to do it like teeth uh
teeth implants
that's another possibility but some
people even reject interesting tooth
implants some people can't have them
because their body just says no i don't
want it and those will be the uh the the
deplorables yeah
all the people are gonna be you know
synced up in society and they're gonna
be part of the network they're gonna be
like the borg and there's gonna be
people who are like outside begging for
for scraps because they're not gonna be
able to work i cannot bring myself to
drill a hole in my head for this is that
what it says that that looks like a hole
it's not a quarter size maybe like a
dime or smaller now if i was paralyzed
and this could help me walk or if i was
blind and it could help me see it's
another we should look up the monkey
because because elon musk did this to
the monkey that was using his brain chip
to play a video game with uh the
monkey's own mind
would you take the chip
again i guess if ian was saying like if
the calculation had changed if i was
if i happened to be paralyzed or had
some horrible disability that could be
fixed with neuralink i think i would be
very much willing to
give it a shot i mean what what do you
have to lose if you're confined to a
wheelchair and and you know this company
says that hey we might be able to make
you walk but that's the that's the pr
public excuse they're going to use for
total domination and attract trace and
database society where they're the tech
overlords of our existence and we're the
peon slaves so uh on that note i do have
to say that as someone who requires kind
of expensive medicine i don't hate big
pharma as much as some people and as
someone who may ultimately end up
requiring something that will keep me
from being in a wheelchair i have to say
this stuff is kind of exciting i'm not
going to probably voluntarily sign up
for neurolink but they when they were
researching some of these mrna vaccines
they found some interesting new
treatments for whatever it is that i
have and i was like that's really neat
so you never know where there's going to
be an advance and i was going to say one
of the things that i'm sure they're
probably thinking about right now is how
your body is going to respond to keeping
this inside your body because you can't
even transplant an organ without
requiring anti-rejection medicine for
the rest of your life because your body
does not want any foreign objects in it
at all like your body rejects tattoo ink
your body rejects everything maybe this
is why they're working so hard towards
artificial intelligence because
the human mind is not programmed it is
developed over a period of time and
itself generates it's it there's like a
base code and when human is born and
over time the neurons connect and each
individual's brain function is unique
like like a brain print almost so how do
you affect how do you interface with a
brain that is unique to itself
self-grown when we make a computer we
take the schematic for the computer we
replicate it a billion times there's our
computer we know how they work they have
interchangeable parts but each
individual human is not the same some
people use a slightly different part of
the brain it grew in a different
position artificial intelligence may be
able to rapidly map out the key areas of
the brain so it can interface very very
quickly yeah it also looks like that
monkey went through surgery like they
opened up his skull and implant
implemented a chip in there because you
don't see any wires on the outside you
see a bald spot on the back of the
monkey's head so it looks like this and
it showed it showed the surgery it
showed the implant being injected after
a cut of the monkey's head so check this
out check this out in the beginning you
can see the monkeys using a joystick and
then i guess later on they get rid of
the joystick now it's just controlling
it with his brain ah that's crazy what
is he's blowing on something or sucking
on something i think it's giving him
food or something okay no i i don't know
maybe we should just watch it and
they'll tell us what he's doing and then
elon musk is looking at human trials in
2022. so next year he's looking at human
beings being these monkeys literally uh
testing out the brain chips here's one
here's what i want to know if you're
gonna be able to type with your thoughts
yeah you're just gonna think a sentence
and it's gonna be on the page that's
right but let me let me let me ask
everybody especially for use uh for for
you guys who are uh watching the show
because i don't there's a lot of people
who i think are absolutely craving and
desiring this
begging for it and there's probably a
lot of people who won't admit it because
that's what i was saying to uh when we
had jack murphy on the show i was like
imagine
you get up you walk over to your
treadmill you throw the towel over your
neck you turn on your neural link and
then all of a sudden you're at old
country buffet
and while you are virtually consuming
massive quantities of food and cakes and
steaks filet mignon all the steak you
can eat you're sitting there eating and
then you get full and you're like that
was awesome
take off the newer link and you're
running on the treadmill and you stop
and you've been running for an hour
you're all sweaty and fit and access and
you weren't even in that you know you
weren't doing the chore of the exercise
now i think it's a fair point a lot of
people like exercise but some people
don't and so jack was like oh man you're
making an attempting or whatever there's
a lot of people and and beyond that too
what if you could take you know you've
got the brain chip and then you could
take a little chip that was like you
know uh elder scrolls 13
put it on your on your brain turn it
boom you're just you're in elder scrolls
you're fighting dragons you're throwing
fireballs they're gonna need to make
elder scrolls 15 cream that i can just
rub on my floor on my third eye and then
i'll that'll
it'll install the game for you you snort
it yeah i don't wanna i don't insert
anything but also you know sacrifice and
pain builds character and and builds an
appreciation for something if you're
just given something i mean obviously
the average human being is going to like
it for a little bit but then become kind
of apathetic to it and not be happy not
be satisfied because they never truly
worked for something that's their own it
was just given to them in this kind of
metaverse and i think this is going to
create a society of very unhappy people
and i don't think it's going to work
have you guys ever seen the commercial
for playstation 9
no you guys want to see it let me play
this video for you guys
new for 2078. that's a smart dust
playstation 9's new electronic spores
tap straight into your adrenal gland yep
that is legit
ps9 has improved retinal scanning
a mind control system
a holographic movie surround vision
and telepathic personal music
the ultimate just got better
playstation nine
teleport yours today
that is great why did they think that it
was gonna take five decades six decades
to get to playstation nine i have no
idea yeah it's creepy though isn't it
dude you're going to be able to
do that but you're going to have like 80
80 games going on at once in your brain
people are going to evolve to multitask
to have be able to think about different
things at the same time and you're going
to this is going to help train us
to do that
in this day and age you can't even tell
if that's parity or not like if you told
me oh this is an official uh sony
commercial jordan i totally believe you
i have no idea what that is but it's
separating these like parody skits from
actual reality everything's becoming so
dystopian nowadays we're just like
living in a weird black mirror episode
when mark zuckerberg shows up and says
oh you're all going to enter the
metaverse with me and we're like what is
actually going on people will do it
i think most people are going to do it i
think
you know we are more likely to be the
outliers who steve bannon talks about it
but steve bannon's on the older side
you you you tell a young kid they're
going to be able to actually go into the
witcher and and live in that world
you're going to tell them your favorite
tv shows you're you're not just going to
watch the tv show you're going to be in
the room as all of that stuff is
happening you're not just going to watch
game of thrones okay bad example game of
thrones but what's what's what's what's
a new hot show hell bound
or squid game you're not just going to
be watching squid game you're going to
be in the games running around as the
stuff is going on and get this you could
actually they could they could make
shows where you can sit and watch it
happen or you could stop things and then
choose to interact with the characters
what if we're in the vr right now what
if we're in the metaverse as we're
speaking right now
then we're not doing it very well let's
level up and beat this i think we're
doing very well i mean i i just do side
quests first okay this is the side we're
still doing side quests okay
oh i was gonna say something
speaking of the simulation isn't that
new matrix movie coming out in a few
days
it sounds so difficult they're going to
discuss
trilogy they're going to destroy all the
hard core like messaging of of freedom
and liberty and against the system
they're going to make it just i think a
total establishment
pro
propaganda of our modern day blue-haired
person that's not there's literally one
of the main characters is like a
blue-haired non-binary person i remember
when i was just saying these kids you're
going to get like a 10 year old being
like okay mom i'm going into the
metaverse and puts on their helmet goes
into their digital shop where they're
selling their nfts and all these they're
like this really well-known salesman in
the verse and then all these people come
out and they're buying all this stuff
and the kid comes out an hour later and
pays for his parents food and and like
you're gonna have the we might see a
society where the kids are paying for
the adults via their digital presence in
the verse the matrix got it wrong
in the matrix they're like humans were
forced to be batteries for the machines
it should have actually been humans
chose to be batteries for the machines
because they got you know the cr it's
like the cipher character in the first
matrix he's like eating steak and he's
like i want to be back in the matrix but
you know i'll tell you one thing that's
going to get crazy too a lot of what
we're seeing about identity issues where
people want to be animals where people
want to be dragons or demon dolls or
whatever i mean legit we talked about
the demon doll woman she identifies as a
demon doll whatever that is
yeah they're gonna they're gonna go in
the metaverse and they're gonna be that
so when that little kid goes into his
metaverse to sell his nfts he's gonna be
like a giant duck and then someone's
gonna walk in and be like duck man what
up let me get some of those nfts i'll
take that one and that one all those
shoes are sick i'm gonna put them on
avatar right now and then he blinks and
then give me a question
give me a quick and then and then the
little kid who's the duck goes
and then the kid comes out he leaves the
metaverse and he walks into the bathroom
he looks in the mirror and just goes
and then he puts the metaverse back on
and he's the duck again
so who's keeping the lights on while
we're on the metaverse it's going to be
done via smart contract the government
the government's going to be taking care
of everyone everyone's going to be on
the on not only just the social credit
score but what was andrew yang talking
about uh you know a pentax that the
government's going to be giving you just
to live what did he call it
the ubi yeah the skype yeah yeah
the propaganda was freedom dividend
freedom
who is going to be running this thing
like is it going to be the corporation
the corporation sounds like an 80s
sci-fi movie the government working with
the corporations hand-in-hand in tandem
with the intelligence agencies calling
the shots just like they do now and
they'll be the same way that they do now
on their own like unique metaverse like
their own
private one that isn't tracked or
something and then they're all and
they're gonna be they're gonna be gms
they're gonna be moderators gonna be
admins you're going to be in the
metaverse and you're going to be like
hey you guys want to come with me to you
know duck store to see the new duck nfts
and you're me walking and then mark
zuckerberg to me walking by and you need
to go oh hey look it's zuckerberg and
then he's just going to turn his head
like a robot he's gonna go
and then he's gonna you know have just
powers in the metaverse he's gonna
delete your your avatar and you're gonna
snap out and be like no i can't beat
that people will work their whole lives
to become admins like i just wanna be a
gm i just wanna be a gym and then they
finally get it they're 35 and they
realize it's not all it's cracked up to
be the hours are long imagine being a
moderator in the metaverse like
someone's walking around in like a big
open space yelling about flat earth or
whatever and then a moderator shows up
and says you know like you're being
banned and then snap the person's gun
robocop imagine imagine if in reality
people had these kinds of powers that
you could be
standing in the middle of public square
holding up a sign saying you know you
know the end is nigh or end the fed or
something and then a cop walks up and
says disturbing the peace snap and then
you just don't exist anymore yeah you
could have ejected a metaverse where
like one guy you're there doing
something another guy comes up and he's
like stop and wants to destroy you in
the metaverse and he destroys you but
from your perspective he explodes
and so you both lose you both win in
your own
experience of the reason as being
possible if there's a centralized server
but i do think this is a really good
argument for why there needs to be if
there is a metaverse it has to be
decentralized and and this actually be a
really cool thing if there was like one
big centralized metaverse server and
they've got moderators guarding the door
and they're like you can't come in but
you could go to any other server people
could host their own private servers
there'd be crazy servers that'd be that
be that that'd be kind of crazy i think
the problem is all of this is predicated
upon whether or not you're going to have
a hole drilled into your head and a
microchip implanted in your brain
which you will and you'll be living
under the ubi and the social credit
score and there'll be smart dust flying
around everywhere making sure you're
compliant with it or else they'll be
injected into your body and then have
the turn-off switch for the have you
heard about the smart dust we've talked
about a little bit uh that's what the
playstation 9 commercial was all about
they released the look we have it right
nanoparticles yeah it's been around for
a while
smart dust is a system of many tiny
micro electromechanical systems mems
such as sensors robots or devices that
can detect for example light temperature
vibration magnetism chemicals they're
used uh they're they're usually operated
on a computer network wirelessly
distributed over air to perform tasks
blah blah they're a few millimeters they
may be vulnerable to electromagnetic
disablement but you get the point it's
not when you say smart dust a lot of
people think it's like tiny and you
can't see it like nanotech for the most
part they're not saying that right now
they're saying it's very very small
sensors and computers that can be used
for
you know tracking manipulating things
yeah but the technology that's being
developed along with the metaverse i
think goes hand in hand with again what
i said before the smart grid the social
credit score and i think it's going to
be crucially implemented in a lot of the
control grid systems that are already
being put into place that are being
developed so well let me
we'll start here we'll start here um
based on what elon musk is saying to
elizabeth warren he's earned my trust oh
my i don't know i don't know if i would
take the computer implant from elon musk
but the story's still pretty funny elon
musk feuds with elizabeth warren over
billionaire taxes senator karen
all right billionaire elon musk fired
back at comments from senator elizabeth
warren on tuesday telling her to stop
projecting and calling her senator karen
i'll just show you exactly what happened
here's on twitter elizabeth warren says
she posts the boston globe elon musk
named times person of the year she said
let's change the rigged tax code so the
person of the year will actually pay
taxes and stop freelancing of everyone
else elon musk said among other things
and if you opened your eyes for two
seconds you would realize i will pay
more taxes than any american in history
this year and elon is correct
the the establishment left with like
faux progressives like warren are able
to convince these progressives to to
believe this stuff just by saying it's
the craziest thing to me that they go
did you know elon musk's elon musk and
amazon paid no taxes and i'm like that's
insanely not true there's like it is
objectively false
it makes no sense on its face why would
you believe that
because they said it elizabeth warren
says it and it gets repeated
it's just not the case um yeah what's
the story with that with when they say
apple paid no corporate taxes this year
is that because their their costs
outweighed their their expenditures
outweigh their
it's usually a manipulation because one
thing you always have to pay taxes on
would be like employment tax property
tax
you've got local taxes state taxes now
federally or even at the state level
they might say you know we invested x we
worked at a deal with the city for a tax
incentive to to put money somewhere and
so quite literally what could happen is
the city goes to apple and says tell you
what if you spend
you know uh 500 million dollars building
a factory here with x amount of jobs
then we'll consider an investment for
tax purposes and and and you know give
you a tax benefit of x and then it's
like
okay
so the government cuts a deal in
exchange for an economic
incentive with with the company and then
the left comes out and says but they're
not paying taxes it's like but they're
doing what the government asked them to
do
so imagine if they came out and said no
government i won't do anything you say
and the government would then be like
okay pay taxes and they'd be like okay
and not only that whenever they say this
they always use weasel words to make it
seem like elon musk pays no taxes elon
musk i i believe is correct when he says
he pays more taxes than any american in
history huh because he's gonna like he's
selling off all his property that's huge
that's gonna dramatically reduce his tax
bill but his tax bill was probably
insanely huge just off of owning things
and so basically this is all about the
stupid wealth tax which makes no sense
where they're like we're gonna tax
people for cash on things that aren't
liquid
which is the dumbest idea ever like you
could have this gorilla right here and
then one day someone's like that's a
rare gorilla it's worth a million
dollars and then all of a sudden i'm
supposed to pay a million dollars
because i have a plastic gorilla thing
on my desk that makes no sense yeah the
the
0.0001 native american senator karen
also really hates cryptocurrencies in
bitcoin and has called for a lot of
regulation a lot of government
intervention and an extremely high tax
rate for people using cryptocurrencies
and bitcoin so there's a big divide
between elizabeth warren and of course
elon musk and elon musk has been on a
tear lately he's been making a lot of
bold big statements specifically saying
that he doesn't want to build back
better bill he thinks that bill should
be absolutely shunned away he thinks
that the united states government is
just a major corporation that has a
monopoly of violence he's been speaking
out against a lot of core issues
including vax mandates saying that
absolutely there shouldn't be any vax
mandates and it's really interesting to
see his talking points and
and i think you know a lot of times
people are are changed politically
especially when they look at the taxes
that they have to pay well out of their
paycheck so i think you know most
definitely elon musk uh saw that the
taxes he had to pay and that kind of
changed him politically being like this
is pissing me off i'm going to voice my
opinions since i'm giving so much money
to these people and these these
multinational corporations it's very
interesting when you do research into
them
these bills these tax increase bills
potential tax presenters bills are going
to screw over small businesses mid-sized
businesses because multinational
corporations i mean i've been covering
pfizer for quite some time now they can
offshore their profits and build the
headquarters in ireland and say you know
we made 50 billion dollars in ireland
we're not paying we're paying 2 in taxes
this year because all of our profits are
in ireland if you're a mom-and-pop shop
that
generates like a gross revenue of a
million dollars
there's no way you're going to be able
to offshore any of your profits so the
these bills senator warren is a total
fraud if you notice that when she talks
about oh we're going to go after wall
street she never names a firm on wall
street that she's going to go after
because she's in their pocket and
they're for some reason there it's
interesting with elon musk you know he's
kind of becoming based now and he's on
the really bad side of the biden
administration to the point where they
had a big electric vehicle meeting at
the white house and how to craft that
bill and they did not invite tesla
that's like not inviting uh you know
sony to the future of video games
conference it's just very bizarre
i want to explain something to to people
about taxes that uh a lot of these
progressives don't understand do you
think that you know bezos cares about
his tax rate
he does not
he's probably like i got too much money
man i don't even know i don't even know
when he gets his paycheck because bezos
gets eighty three thousand eighty one
thousand dollars a year sorry it's his
salary and then he gets incentives which
ultimate like bonuses he ultimately
comes out to about 1.6 million he
probably looks at and goes oh
because how much money do you really
need to get by
so bezos has his stock he has his assets
he has tons of money but at the end of
the day he gets his paycheck and he
probably says
i don't even look at it he probably just
ignores it outright because it's
meaningless
now a poor person i remember
my it was like my third job i was
working for an airline out of o'hare
airport
and i'd worked 40 hours at 10 bucks an
hour and so i was like all right so it's
gonna be what it's gonna it's like
that's 400 bucks and then i got to pay
taxes so i imagine maybe i'll end up
with you know 300 to 350 we'll see what
happens and my paycheck was like 2 270
something and then i got my paycheck and
i looked at it and i just was like i
just was like what the
and then all the older guys where they
started laughing and they were like he
saw the taxes didn't he
and then i was like dude i'm poor i
can't afford to live
like working 40 hours at 10 bucks an
hour and then being told that
almost half of the money i'm making was
like 28 or whatever it's taken from me i
needed those hours i needed that money i
couldn't afford rent i couldn't afford
my car i couldn't afford health care but
when you're rich and they go we're going
to take you've got your salary is 10
million dollars we're taking half you go
i don't know so what's my paycheck this
this this month
488 000
whatever deposit it i'm sitting on
assets i don't care i don't even notice
so these tax increases are not gonna are
negligible to a lot of these people well
a lot of the super rich have called for
more tax increases because it makes sure
that they stay on top and their
competition doesn't have an opportunity
to have enough income to be able to
compete with them so you know these
people want higher taxes because it
actually benefits them they want more
regulations they want a higher minimum
wage because at the end of the day it's
destroying small mom-and-pop businesses
while of course it's benefiting them
greatly and they have other ways they
have so many different incentives
whether it's setting up offshore
corporations and then selling off the
intellectual property towards a domestic
company here in the united states
there's so many different rules there's
a reason the tax code is as big as it is
because there's a lot of exemptions for
a lot of powerful people that helped
write it that works in their favor that
obviously screws everyone else who would
be competition to those people exactly
this big this builds back better bill
that they're promote promoting in
congress and that uh joe biden's all
about and all those people are all about
this was crafted by the lobbyists for
the giant corporations it's by and for
these giant corporations it is not to uh
you know help our our economic engine it
is as luke said it's to seal off the
competition from these oligarchs that's
that's the entire purpose of it it's
it's this state corporate enterprise
they want to they want to phase out all
types of
possible competition
yeah yeah
yeah i was just thinking about taxes man
yeah just i'm just like
i'm going through the numbers and it's
interesting that
i'm imagining
back when i was younger and trying to
calculate budget how many hours this
week do i have to work to get by and how
how taxes really brutalize you when
you're making just enough to be above
poverty or whatever they take taxes out
anyway and it's like if you if you got
to pay 500 bucks a month in rent and you
can only work 40 hours a week like
you're going to be struggling to make
ends meet if you've got rent food health
insurance whatever you want the bare
minimum then any amount of taxes taken
out is is gutting you
dude to be told that
you know you're going to lose uh 230 you
know effectively like 23 hours of the
work you did that week or 20 hours of
the of of the work you did that week
it's like why even do it if you're
working that much to have it taken away
from you maybe maybe it's unfair to say
that much maybe it's like you know 13
hours or whatever
the point is
for people who are extremely well off
you could tell you could you could tell
that ultra rich person were taking 90
and they'd be like i don't know i don't
care about my income anyway because
everything's in hard assets and
everything's accruing in value so what
does that even mean to me it's in
property it's in stocks and but this is
this is the problem that when that when
they say they want to raise taxes across
the board i mean even bernie sanders
plan i think would have still raised
taxes for like middle class and upper
middle class people and what i try to
explain to a lot of people uh and occupy
wall street for instance and and other
leftist activists
what we need in my opinion
is more tax brackets not just to be like
after you make 250 000 we tax you at
this percentage because somebody who
makes 250 000 being taxed you know
48 or whatever or 38 i think it is then
they end up getting take home about 100
or so thousand dollars but somebody
who's making 10 million dollars who's
taxed the same rate
doesn't notice a difference when they're
having millions of dollars deposited in
their account i have a little bit of a
different perspective i think there
should be no taxes and if the government
wants to launch any project they have to
do it through gofundme and they have to
have enough public support and private
charity to do so i think that would be a
more rational way to do this than of
course steal people's money yeah i like
that for some except for like utilities
about like water the water supply and
the power supply
the military if you look at most power
supply companies especially in
california it is riddled with corruption
you look at venezuela and their kind of
energy companies when when they were of
course brought into the state government
it absolutely ruined venezuela the
infrastructure hasn't been updated the
government has no incentive in order to
provide you any quality of service the
private market does and that's why i
would argue the government getting
involved makes the situation that much
worse
what about with the water supply because
if the water supply goes haywire the
government well it depends on like what
aspect and what variability you're
you're discussing like are we talking
about sanitation are we talking about
sanitation cleaning
yeah who's going to take my poop from my
house that's right luke and you're in
your and your ron paul and kappa stand
paradise where's poop go you could
there's literally companies out there
that are developing technology that
makes poop into it's true energy
and and and power so so the private
market would be again way better i'm not
saying it's going to be a perfect system
obviously with any system there's going
to be some kind of harm there's going to
be some kind of idiot that ruins it for
everyone else but i think overall there
would be a lot less harm a lot more
economic prosperity a lot more freedom
just like we saw in singapore just like
we saw a few years ago in hong kong
civilization
bro they execute you if they find you
now now they do but but singapore
became known on the world stage as a
free economic market where a lot of
people fled to and it was able to build
a society that that was a free market
society that allowed private enterprise
to thrive and it created some of the
most richest people um in the world now
obviously has devolved into a full
technocratic state with a social credit
score with surveillance cameras watching
your every move if you spit on the
ground or if you chew gum the wrong way
i thought
i was sweating bullets in singapore uh
with tim because of uh a disgruntled
tinder date was was saying
that that she was going to call the
police on me for not going on the day
they got here you got catfish oh it was
bad it was a horrible i luckily was able
to kind of see it and then we had to
like escape out the back door whatever
was funny i was laughing the whole time
yeah uh luckily i made it out but i was
sweating bullets um apart what was
happening there it's a crazy way that
they decided to live their lives but
anywhere you see the free market kind of
activated
you see a lot of individual freedom you
see a lot of liberty you see a lot of
services that are incentivized to help
the person rather than a government that
will take your money and then doesn't
need to provide you a good service what
if uh what if we created like a special
economic zone in the united states yeah
that was like totally you know free
market we had two different ones one was
for the commies and one was for the end
caps and you could choose which one you
wanted to go live in perfect that would
be absolutely beautiful one city is
dedicated to the communists and once
you're once you choose to live there you
can't choose not to and then the free
marketplace you can come and go as you
please exactly and then if if you know
commies want to live in their own
commune go ahead um
i won't be mad about it would you no tim
your cold weather guy right what about
greenland big property over there free
economy yeah i know and trump wanted to
buy it and i was like that sounds great
yeah and they made fun of him for it
it's so weird because like it wasn't
even that long ago we bought alaska you
know i mean
exactly and it would provide so much you
know
opportunities uh it would provide a lot
of expansion it would provide
you know potentially an economic free
zone which i think would be amazing and
if you look at the history of those they
always turn out into incredible things
you look at the history of government
top down centralization controlling
every aspect of the financial
institutions you see communism and you
see uh
people starving and not having food
people being slaughtered and sent to the
gulags and i think there's a big overall
trend when it comes to economic freedom
and political freedom we need star link
we need um
we need low latency high-speed satellite
internet then then you can live and work
from anywhere and that's what i'm
excited for because
we we've been looking at you know we're
in west virginia we're setting up this
big 50 acre property but we're still out
here
because we have to be close to a major
airport or whatever and so that will
tether us in our operation you know
closer to you know bigger cities but you
could go to a smaller regional airport
and someone could fly to a major airport
then to the smaller airport and then you
could effectively have a a media
operation in the middle of wyoming in
the middle of nowhere so long as you
have that satellite and that low latency
communication or greenland and
decentralized service server space
that's once we get starlink and like
maybe satellite server space too orbital
server space i think we're going to be i
think the future the future of this
planet is going to be people spreading
out outside of cities and then wiring
themselves into the into the metaverse
and living digital virtual lives could
you imagine just like if if your entire
life
was the matrix but it wasn't like the
movie the matrix you knew you were in
the matrix so basically you'd like wake
up in the morning and you you'd brush
your teeth then you'd go into your pod
you know that stimulates your muscles so
you don't atrophy and then you enter
the digital space and then you're you're
in green land you know doing your work
and you're like i got a meeting in new
zealand and then so then you just walk
up to a door and you you type you know
you activate it uh new zealand please
the door opens right open and you walk
right to new zealand
because you're in a virtual world dude
it'll be like i'll be in my house you'll
be in your house but we'll both be in
this studio digitally it'll look like it
that we're both sitting next to each
other and we'll be seeing each other you
can do that now and the video will look
like we're all in the room together well
yeah because you'll be we'll be wired in
the matrix but here's the thing so we're
all
kind of against it now but because if
we're talking about this future
technology in the sense that they can
like kind of like regulate your dopamine
we will all become addicted to the
metabolism that's the problem it's not
even about that it's not going to be
it's not going to be that tomorrow you
know elon musk knocks on your door and
then like you know he's holding the chip
and then two guys in white coats pin you
down and you're like nah
it's gonna be that they're gonna roll
out the the the neural cap
it's a hat you wear that can you know um
alert you when you're when your phone
goes off or something like that or
google glass it's going to be some small
convenience we accept and then every day
the convenience is going to escalate
think about how cell phones started
big big gray block you pulled the
antenna up it had like four hours of
power only worked downtown and they
sucked and then i remember when you know
my mom had a cell phone it was like
roaming charges and connections and it
like worked it was better it was like a
gray motorola and you'd flip it down
then i got my first candy bar phone
these phones didn't do anything but it
was convenient to have you could talk to
people or beepers for instance now we
have the summation of the access to the
summation of human knowledge in our
pockets we can film videos it is
escalating
everyone accepts it they're okay with
being tracked they're okay with being
spied on because of the convenience so
neural link will happen whatever all
this medivar stuff will happen no one
will resist it we are going to accept it
and be happy about it how many people if
you went back in time
and said i'm gonna take away your
landline phone and you will be happy
they'd be like no i wouldn't i need my
phone be like no no don't worry we're
gonna give you a tracking device that
people can track everywhere you go no
matter where you go and it'll spy on you
but you'll be able to talk to people
they'll be like screw that are you nuts
no give me my phone back
that's not that's not where we're at now
is it so i'm watching the chat room and
someone just left a comment saying
imagine this chat but in vr and i'm like
oh
that would be wild i'm seeing what you
guys are saying here it's it's crazy it
already exists
there's uh on oculus there's i don't
know what it's called it's like live
chat and
i'm i brought up the duck thing of that
little kid because i was playing the
game i was playing space robot trainer
that pirate game that's so fun you're
like you got robots and you're like
you're shooting at him and then i went
to the chat room and it's like people
walking around and there was a duck just
like walking around doing stuff and i'm
like someone literally went in this game
and said i'd like to be a duck and they
did the the graphics are trash mind you
because the processing power isn't all
that great or whatever but imagine what
it's going to be like when they
synchronize neuralink how long is that
going to be 10 years 20 years
maybe maybe maybe that's a bad estimate
maybe 30 or 40. or could be still much
sooner than that i know look out look at
look at 1986 1981
the video games that were out mario
brothers
30 years look where video games ended up
you you've got
first person 3d now look where we are
it's been almost 40 years it's been over
40 years and look how rapidly video game
technology has advanced to the point
where now we got vr glasses you with
with the new oculus you put it on and
there's no wires you can go out in your
backyard and set your space and then
just do whatever in virtual reality
wireless yup i keep thinking about the
chip did you guys see the video the
chimp on instagram
let's just look it up someday i don't
know if you want to bring it up now it's
it's kind of a non-sequitur
what about this it's just a chimpanzee
on instagram he's on instagram swiping
and he's like it looks like a human like
this is oh this right here yeah this is
nuts is this there we go
i mean we are he's just he's animals
he's watching videos of chimps doing
chimp stuff yeah
chimps
well yeah but chimps are smart monkeys
you know monkeys are smart too
we'll be we'll be in the metaverse with
these guys
look at that he's swiping he's looking
for stuff he just he hits it and he's
like yo what up that may help us
understand other animals a lot better
because if we can wire them knows how to
do it like if you could neural net and
synchronize with an ape and then you can
kind of understand the animal
more i don't know man and it could
understand you more i think i think
everything that we're saying is going to
be viewed in the future as like stodgy
old people
complaining when we laughed at remember
that guy
jim i don't know if you know this ian
there's a guy who uh who was it was it
it was it was someone famous he said the
internet wouldn't take off oh robert
reich wasn't it was it i think so is
that krugman it was crazy
and he was like the internet will not be
part of the economy or something like
this he likened it to a fax machine he
said it would be as big a deal as a fax
machine i think that was the quote
let's see what he did krugman say the
internet's effect on the world economy
would be no greater than the fax
machines true
look at that man this guy is still today
a very dumb nobel prize winning
economist that's right wow about
everything
but think about it man people back then
i remember watching you know i watched
these old videos that come up where
they're like no the internet's not gonna
take off well certainly an interesting
novelty it won't be and then you get
krugman you gotta people like it
watching these old videos about the
internet it's crazy because it is life
today well you know even with cell
phones and the advent of social media i
would say it was a net positive in the
very beginning because it was unfiltered
uncontrolled there was no major
algorithms it was what you subscribe to
is what you get and there was a moment
in time where people finally started to
get the true window to the reality of
the world that wasn't controlled by any
kind of special interest
now those doors are closing and i s and
i'm seeing social media as a net
negative especially with the
psychological disorders that it has
caused so many young people causing
people to of course be so unhappy but
the larger debate that i think should be
sparked here is it because we have too
much knowledge that has gone into our
brain too fast is the ability to be able
to know anything in a moment something
that is detrimental to human society or
human beings a power that they never had
before that's an interesting kind of
debate that i've been kind of listening
and hearing about that i think is worth
talking about in 50 years people are all
born
and they're implanted with their neural
chip
and they grow up
and they live mostly in the metaverse
and there's a young man he meets a young
woman and they're getting along
swimmingly and they're all excited and
then they're like you know oh i've gotta
i've gotta move pods um
you know oh i'll come help you move your
pod and then the guy's like that that'd
be great yeah they're coming to move the
pod to unit c39 over you know about a
block from my house it's gonna be a lot
of work it's gonna be annoying and then
you know one day there's a knock on the
door and it's like a six foot three
really burly bearded man and he's like
rick good to see you and he's like janet
and they hug and they kiss and then they
carry the pot out to the new unit then
they go back in their pods and you know
the big bearded guy is actually a five
foot seven blonde woman in the metaverse
like i'm not even kidding like it's
gonna be normal and people are gonna be
like whatever because their reality the
reality is going to be the metaverse and
the real world base reality is going to
be a chore it's going to be ancillary
it's going to be like something they
have to deal with
it's going to hurt
it's right gravity hurts yup it's going
to be like you know when you're like in
a pool and when you get out you're like
oh man like no no cold it's like all of
a sudden like when you're under when
you're in the water you can move much
more easily and then when you lift up
you're like whoa i'm heavy now and
you've got all this water holding you
down that's what it's going to feel like
people are going to live that way it's
like in the movie surrogates where
there's that hot blonde woman and then
like the machine blows her head up they
go to the apartment and it turns out
it's this morbidly obese guy who's in
the machine like hooking up with kids
there's something to that in the age of
gender fluidity where like you can be
any gender and you can pick your avatar
kind of i mean it totally synergizes
with what you're saying yeah yep what do
you think what's the future going to
look like in a few years from now so
from a technological aspect um you know
you have the famous moore's law but what
you find so i think this might be a
problem of our progeny i don't know i'm
not convinced it's going to happen so
fast because technological innovation in
the electronic space is actually slowing
down there's only
so you have a circuit board and there's
only so many transistors that you can
pack on there so it's probably going to
take something like a neuralink
technology you know totally flip the
board over start working on like brain
electrodes because in terms of like
improvement of technology the idea it is
no longer exponential and it hasn't been
for for quite some time it's actually
eventually going to flatten out because
th this this circuit board technology
it's already like
done by robots and microscopic there's
literally like no more room for these
electrons
the transistors have transistors have
become so small that electrons aren't
even falling on the path they're jumping
off and moving between things they're
using sound now as a wave guide to mu to
force the electrons along the path so
they don't actually have to use i don't
want to get this wrong i don't know more
about it but they're using sound to
guide the light yeah so with a neural
link if you're doing brain surgery then
who knows where this takes off but if
you're trying to use like your oculus to
expand into the metaverse i don't see it
as being something so similar to human
life through that platform
but again when you're when you're
dealing with the brain who knows what
could happen so what if in the future we
stopped making you know
computer chips and we started growing
brain matter and then you're like dude
the new uh ryzen threadripper
5000
organic and it's like a brain in a fat
and it's got like ports and everything
we start having cone heads just like in
them in the hollywood movies and because
there's also
we're using we're using our own brains
as our desktops is what you're saying no
no no just like in in the conehead movie
their brains just like start expanding
upwards uh and there's also that wasn't
in the conad's movie uh yes it was no
they're just aliens with coneheads
exactly we could become
they probably had bigger brains no
right they have bigger i don't know but
there's also a set of human beings that
are recorded uh with their skeletons
having cone heads that's if they were
doing elongation some people are
debating that but there's also some
other interesting theories by brian
forrester that uh contradict that theory
as well um i don't know what the truth
is but um if we're gonna be expanding
brains i'm pretty sure it's gonna be
coneheads you know i was thinking about
i think what we should do is um now that
vax mandates are normal we should
actually just have a metaverse mandate
and then we should have to send the
government out to forcefully neurolink
chip people's brains and plug them plug
them in against their will because once
you connect them to metaverse and you
can control their thoughts you can take
away the pain and then they'll like it
perfect so all we have to do is chase
people down while chanting one of us one
of us perfect and they'll be scared at
first but as soon as you infect them
with the with the metaverse they'll
easily calm down and then join you in
your quest
to transform everyone else into a
singular being you know just like the
independent says we have to de-regulate
or de-uh radicalize the hardcore
anti-vaxxers uh and treat them like
terrorists you know so
i don't know what that has to do with it
that's the independent it's all for the
greater good tim send them to the verse
in the name of health for the greater
good
right now we'll read super chat so if
you haven't already get in that super
chat smash that like button if you ever
know you smash that like button do it
for ian do it for me do it for you and
go to timcast.com become a member we
have a members only segment coming up
around 11 or so p.m let's read what you
got we got public news choice says buy
yourself a beer tim always enjoy tuning
in when i get off work hey appreciate it
man we actually just started getting a
bunch of new beers from a new brewery
what is it what is it called it's old
690 brewery there's one now old 690. so
it's a it's a local brewery but
apparently
they're freedom loving brewery yeah they
love freedom pretty good beer yeah we we
met some we met some of the owners and
we talked to them they were really cool
um uh one of the family members is a fan
of the show and we went and grabbed a
whole mess load of their beers
we might actually do a our a brew with
them a cat that sounds fun tim cast
castle specific brew of some sort i had
a raspberry one i think for raspberry
wheat
you got to call it like beanie juice
beanie cheese
no i think we can make something good we
have yeah we have a blonde and we've and
so we do have that i don't really drink
all that much but i did drink a little
bit recently just for the holidays so
i've been having a good time you know
we've got these these these uh the new
brews and i think um gotta try them out
you gotta try both i need to have a
blonde one maybe i'll one tomorrow
all right let's see
beep boop says tim would enjoy arcane
season one it follows a nation named
piltover and it's and it's slum that's
attempting to break away and create its
own nation good night oh interesting
i'll check it out isn't that the um is
it the league of legends show
no idea yeah arcane arcane dunno
cliff says that anyone else ever noticed
the omicron variant when unjubaled
actually spells out veronic
yes
yeah a lot of people have pointed that
out i guess michael tracy said that we
should be calling omnicron the um what
was the variant um hold on i i actually
written it down because it's a very it's
that good huh yeah it was pretty good
he wants it to be like oh come on
variant oh come on now you know what i'm
excited for i'm actually really excited
for the omega variant yeah because it
sounds so like
dark and scary like like a sci-fi
dystopia would it be cool to be living
in a sci-fi dystopia i think we do
but
so so a lot of people said they skipped
the she variant and the new variant they
skipped a whole bunch yeah they think
they just get better ones
no no they did that it was around and
lambda but i was looking at the grief
alphabet and i'm like they just skipped
over like seven variants theta
i don't know all i know is like
the omega variant
you know that's gonna be cool voucher's
gonna come out and be like i'm warning
you everyone the omega variant is here
and we're gonna take the video because
the omega it's like
i am the omega i am the science
that's that's what that sounds like
something to say tina collette says as a
resident of wyoming i can say most
people agree liz cheney does not speak
for wyoming and probably will be looking
to move elsewhere when her term is over
soon why don't y'all like recall or
impeach her huh how do you look into the
crimes of the cheney family and
halliburton and getting this into iraq
and then make sure that people that do
that don't stay in positions of power
and politics and their family
i don't know about barring their family
from politics but aren't there enough
people in wyoming to be like
aren't there enough people in wyoming
who don't like liz cheney to just recall
her tim do you have a good book um on
your on your shelf there called rigged
by molly hemingway and guess where molly
hemingway is from
wyoming is she really yeah we gotta we
gotta get her to run against oh hey hey
cal miller says good luck trying to
convince reddit and the vote blew no
matter who people that trump was not
trying to start an insurrection almost
all of reddit's main politics sub is
about trump and january 6. yeah i know
these people live in a weird paranoid
delusional reality i don't know what
it's about
yup
okay what happened did you just freeze
on me okay eric miller says hey tim is
that a mitch mcconnell impression or a
chris wallace impression eh either
either they're both establishment trash
either way also i think the vaccine
mandates are actually triggering a rise
in a civil war i think so yeah chris
walls and mitch mcconnell could
basically basically be the same
impersonation right
it's interesting to hear about these
these vax mandates i mean i live in
south florida i've lived there for a
year and
no one was really wearing masks around
me or anything and we've all been okay
florida actually has the lowest uh
coveted cases um
per capita in the nation and has that
for like two months now if you watch
without these mandates and if you watch
jimmy kimmel he's like desantis is the
is is governor omicron and he's going to
get everyone sick and they're going to
die and i'm like do people really
believe that like the cdc shows florida
has the lowest amount of cases
they've done a really great job but
that's the paranoid delusional reality
they live in huh
the golden gorilla says luke says dems
and republicans are two heads on the
same snake my version is they're
different cheeks on the same ass that
works and they both uh you know
relinquish a lot of ways your cheeks are
the same ass yeah that's a pretty good
one i like that they're full of crap and
they're full of crap
oh that's great wow we should make you
got to make a shirt that's not really
what i'm sure we would make you should
make that
i don't know if they'll allow me to have
butt cheeks on my uh shirt maybe it
might confuse people if it's like maybe
maybe there's another way to do it you
know
there's a lot of words here so
i don't know do you have like nancy
pelosi mitch mcconnell's face tattoo two
cheeks
no it could be like a donkey you know it
could be a donkey in his cheeks since a
democrat republican two cheeks in the
same ass it has to be oh there you go
yeah
green jeans says do you support article
5 if so why don't you discuss a
convention of states more often to get
your audience involved
hey i say it all the time
shout out to the convention of states
if you want to get something done get
the politicians to do something that
they're not going to vote for themselves
to do like
term limits or cutting their salaries
that's convention estates is for
yeah um what i often say is we need to
vote local you need to vote your your
city council your school board you got
to vote for your mayor you got to vote
for your state reps your state senators
you got to vote for your governors and
you got to vote for everybody else and
you got a primary you got to make sure
you're in the party primaries so you can
make sure these establishment uniparty
shills don't get elected but if if
people focus on state level elections
senators and reps then you will get a
convention of states and the federal
government becomes a side note
so there you go
slot b joe says please tell luke that
it's exacerbated not exacerbated listen
i'm going to pronounce words like i want
to pronounce words and if i want to say
exacerbate i'm going to say exacerbate
maybe i'm doing it on purpose yeah luke
speak good and whatever yeah i speak
good
speak good so good
waffle sensei says tim i appreciate the
attempted white pill bro but none of my
lefty friends have any idea what's
happening with the economy it's like
they believe it's not happening this is
correct they live in a paranoid
delusional state i want to tell you
that's why i say the factions and in the
culture warn everything are not left and
right i am i am on the left of
vosh and hassan when it comes to
corporate power and the commons when it
comes to social media platforms
literally i believe that the public
should be in control of public spaces
where communications happen and i don't
believe that massive multinational
private corporations should have the
right to eject people from the commons
but they actually disagree with that
so
they're more in favor of private
property in that capacity for whatever
reason i don't know maybe i'm not
understanding their positions we'd have
a conversation about it but the real
issue is there are people who believe
cnn and there are people who don't
there's there's your narrative but i
shouldn't say cnn it's actually the the
the narrative the establishment
narrative
yeah
rhino says watched a youtube video
earlier and mit has a program called
world 3 that predicted the downfall of
civilization around 2040 then they
mentioned we are on the fast track i i
remember we talked about that didn't we
i don't remember yeah we talked about
the mit's predicting total societal
collapse yeah world three that's the
first to put a name to it
all right
jeff's video says jordan great to see
you somewhere besides the steve diese
show hooked him up with him so he can
have him on his show always great seeing
you man keep it the good work
really appreciate that steve dace is a
great show on blaze tv
there you go
bc is me says write a song for step on
snack and find out done we will do that
i could probably write something like
that in five minutes i'll pick four
chords and i'll just sing off top of my
head and i'll probably you know probably
be able to crank that one out but uh you
know
moose code says tim ever heard of second
life yes i have
it is a metaverse launched in 2003
people have already gotten married and
provided services for money ever since
yeah it was it was mostly just kind of
like an mmo though wasn't it like not an
rpg but a massive multiplayer online
game
mmog
yeah
people you could say it was my property
rpg but it was basically like yeah like
a digital space where you had an avatar
chat room mark zuckerberg didn't put his
weight behind it and elon musk wasn't
trying to drill a hole in your head it
wasn't metaverse and that there wasn't
cryptocurrent like currency wasn't
involved yet um there wasn't any ai
involved
and social networking wasn't integrated
really i mean the game itself was kind
of a insulated social network
all right
tarka says hey everyone could you all
share and help my friends go fund me i
set up she is now hospitalized and a lot
of people won't help because she has had
the vaccine it's called helping jordan
get her life better by nick downes i
gotta tell you man
like some of the some of the data that
i've read about covet i really do think
the initial short-term lockdown was the
right thing to do i'm talking about two
weeks slow the spread the problem was
you give someone an inch to take a mile
right so when i was i was talking to
someone recently about the data
having had covet and and going through
it i'm like we all agreed that the first
when they said 15 days slow spread we
were all kind of like okay we get it you
know it's because we don't want
hospitals to be overwhelmed and that is
all true overwhelming hospitals means
people die of other things too but then
you get
democratic governors killing old people
you get a whole bunch of really bad
stuff happening and so now the challenge
is if you could go back in time and say
no
no no no to any of the authority
emergency powers and lockdowns would you
do it the problem is you know hindsight
is 20 20 we don't know what would have
happened but i kind of think that the
abuse of power we've seen so far is not
worth the exchange that means people
have lost their lives though so i don't
know man it's tough they're still losing
their lives i guess if cuomo with cuomo
and these other governors killing all
these elderly maybe we would have been
better off just not locking down at all
you know maybe if we had preventative
treatments that uh you know actually are
preventative and actually were there
maybe then we would having to deal with
a lot of the loss yeah the counter
example here is is sweden belarus never
locked down yep um if i don't want
florida's doing great too big into uh
the weeds on this issue due to the
regulations on this issue but um yeah
sweden and belarus never locked down
florida lockdown for
i they barely locked down did like a
couple weeks
um it's interesting when you trace back
the two weeks of stopped spread it's
essentially
traced back to this like random school
educator that was running like this
online school and he had a medium post
that went viral
um and then of course the initial idea
of the lockdown came in wuhan china
where they had like all these bizarre
videos coming out and somehow appearing
on western social media platforms like
how did a china a video out of wuhan
make its way to instagram kind of weird
because no one uses instagram and china
so there's a lot of weird questions
about the this this not lockdown
narrative how it started what exactly
happened in wuhan china that they were
um you know pushing out all this random
social media information and trying to
influence the west into locking down and
sadly lockdowns are now like accepted
facts that you know all of these um i
guess progressives and and statists say
you know if there's a covet problem we
need a lockdown uh in addition to our
vax passports in addition to our mass
mandates it's just one totalitarian
measure after the next and they they
they refuse to admit that they got
anything wrong and they're just doubling
tripling quadrupling down on this
craziness but i think they're just like
hey we can keep expanding our powers i
don't think they care at all about the
data or the metrics they're just quite
literally like the more this keeps
happening look at what de blasio said he
wants to buy up property for pennies on
the dollar and convert it to public
housing so they don't care about any of
this other than we can exploit this for
power you you think those videos of uh
the whaling people in china that one
ominous video of like the the howling in
the city and you could hear like you're
rattling chains and stuff you think that
was seated you know that video i'm
talking about i can't really expand out
here but uh my my platform uh i've
written several stories about this at
dossier
let's talk about it let's talk about it
uh in the member segment yeah all right
let's read some more super chats we got
bailey and he says tim wondering if you
do alaska a solid and try to get kelly
chewbacca on see if she's worth it like
you did for a z well um you know with
with arizona i mean we just we wearing
people on have conversations so
we'll have a conversation with anybody
is kelly uh she's running for governor
and yeah let's get that down
is she running for governor i don't know
well we'll take a look
i will look lin ross says elites plan on
creating a metaverse one of the key
problems is gamers we will find ways to
exploit our way to infinite wealth or
find ways to speed run to the top of
their system you know what i used to
love man
o.g world of warcraft glitch hopping on
top of uh you know undercity and and and
going underneath stormwind and doing all
these really fun things we would we
would go into areas that weren't yet
developed we would like you could look
on the map and see an area that's never
been developed and we would find a way
to break into it this is before flying
was introduced to the game
that was the most fun i'd have playing
these games i'd spend hours exploring
this massive virtual world and trying to
find ways to get into places you can't
get into when the division first came
out there was a way to to push through
walls using the ballistic shield and
then we went into a bunch of areas where
the game hadn't released them yet and
they banned you for it and then there
was destiny you could use your vehicle
it's called the sparrow if you spawned
it at the right spot in front of a wall
you would spawn in it would spawn in the
wall you could move through the wall and
go into areas that were unreleased and
they would ban you for it and i'm like
the most fun was exploiting and finding
these things so i'll tell you this they
come out with a metaverse it's going to
be only a matter of time before a group
of hackers find a way to break through
walls
think about how crazy the world's going
to be
when everyone is born it gets a computer
chip and spends 95 of their lives in the
metaverse but some people find exploits
you that would be like if you went
downtown to grab a slice of pizza and
you saw some dude jump 20 feet in the
air and then teleport you'd be like what
how did he do that dude you're making me
think of otto warmbier that that high
school student that went to north korea
and stole a flag and they threw him in
north korean prison he basically wasted
away and died of what they said botulism
so a kid's going to go in the metaverse
from age 2 to 12 and then all of a
sudden he's going to find an exploit and
get banned and he's going to wake up and
start screaming and crying and realizing
that his entire life has been taken from
and then commits suicide and i don't
know i don't know i think i think if
metaverse becomes our entire lives it
would be like you'd get a suspension and
so what they would do is you'd be locked
out of a ton of features you couldn't go
to certain areas and you'd be like oh
man it would be like a yeah we need a
constitution and a government and like a
decentralized organization of power for
something like that because that is
someone's life and it's a private
company they can do what they want
and you don't need to raise your
children you can just put a vr
system on them that raises them for you
that's going to be creepy
babies
indoctrination public school centers in
vr
matrix bro
kids are going to be born into it they
never want to leave
there's there's going to be like it's 50
years this guy's going to be like
my my pod needs to be moved
they're like oh dude that sucks i know
all right well give me a few minutes
i'll deal with this
it's going to be like miserable to have
to leave first baby's gonna be born in
the metaverse they're gonna like we
wanna deliver our baby in the metaverse
and th the baby's gonna be pre-wired to
be in the verse before it even is out of
the womb so you'll see the whole process
the baby will come out and the adult
content that already is on the internet
imagine that being
dude so here's an important one sarah
roberts says i'm paralyzed from the
shoulders down and have been for seven
years but the idea of having a chip
implanted into my head doesn't sit well
it could be amazing but it could also go
very wrong yeah now i'll say in my
opinion if for some people people who
are paralyzed
if i was if i was if i had a spinal
injury i'd take the chip in two seconds
oh yeah me too yeah i don't know i don't
think i would i think i would join this
super chatter to be honest with you yeah
i'm saying i'm saying i'm saying that
now i'm not in that position but from
from that kind of perspective i think i
would take her position after like a
year of like 10 000 people getting up
and walking that are had paralyzation or
it's hard to say because you're not in
your shoes but i understand where she's
coming from yeah i'd do it
i'd be like elon help
wire me up i want to walk
what you're not paralyzed though
i if i was paralyzed i would take the
chip
dude we're healing the blind the the
death
if you lost your eyes would you get that
thing that jordy had the visor from star
trek would you implant the thing in your
anything
anything
to heal my vision at that point but okay
so all right so think about that right
to heal your vision to gain a sense what
if they said we could give you uh an
implant that gives you the ability to
see electrical fields
yeah dude but that would be like getting
an elective surgery for no reason you
can already see
it's cool right yeah i'm not into that
i'm not going to do it for uh
just for basic enhancement but but if i
lost a limb or something and i could get
it regrown i would i'd be into it
that's going to happen in the future
they're going to give you like an enzyme
treatment that's going to like trigger
cellular stem cell regrowth and then
your arm is going to start regrowing and
then you're going to grow back your head
you'll be like a tank of fluid while it
regrows over like two weeks or something
yeah it's faster you'll be in the
hospital and you'll be like check it out
and you're like people will film time
lapses and put them on instagram and
stuff it'll have a tattoo already on it
they're like would you like anything
cool on your new arm oh can i get like
like a wolverine claws we can do
wolverine clubs but can you gotta
register
so there was a funny viral post where a
woman said the craziest thing
was when i was getting my prosthetic
they asked me if i'd like to be taller
and i said yes and now i'm two inches
taller
so when this chick was getting a
prosthetic leg they were like we can
make you taller of course they can yeah
they want and so because he's made a
taller leg and now she's tall that's so
crazy right
frank says there may be a big backlash
with radical luddite groups attacking
tech
we should just make this movie can we
write this radical luddite yeah where
like people are raiding metaverse
facilities and mark zuckerberg is old
and he's like stop you don't understand
we must do this and they're like screw
you zuckerberg and then they start
smashing the servers and yeah the
character in the metaverse is gonna be
you gotta understand i'm not who you
thought i was this is this is this is a
more than what you think it is there's
an actual universe outside of it we need
to free you from trying to free people
from the pods and the bug juice that
they keep feeding them the bug juice so
this is the post metaverse scenario
so what happens the metaverse fails have
you seen that what's that netflix show
where they reprogrammed their
consciousness is that like the post
metaverse step
i forgot what that was called was that
black mirror no no there there's like a
there's a netflix series there's there's
two seasons now i'm sure someone in the
chat knows what it is but but basically
like
your body is totally separate from your
consciousness and that's carbon
yeah yeah so that could be metaverse 3.0
after the first metaverse revolution
put it right in your consciousness here
we go from waffle sensei says tim watch
matrix legends it's canon that the
humans did choose to be enslaved in a
perfect reality that was the deal they
made to end the war
interesting
i'll check that out maybe that's where
the uh the new movie actually goes
because i'm wondering like how do they
do this movie i thought that they had a
truce and like the war was over in the
last matrix and now it's like neo's
taking blue pills or whatever
i don't know man
mason wolfie says
first the brain chip and metaverse then
sword art online oh boy would a dystopia
to be alive and
it's not going to be a dystopia
when you are forcefully enter you know
when they pin you down and inject you
with the with the chip you know and
connect you to the network and then you
go ah
and then also you're sitting in class
and you're like what what just happened
they'd be like bro the quiz the lecture
and you're gonna be like oh oh man oh
what was going on i can't i can't
remember it's like dude we were just we
were just talking about this you're like
oh yeah oh let's go get lunch and then
you're getting it's like it's like
downloading information like i don't
quite oh oh oh i remember i remember
the download completes yep
um did you are you guys know sword art
online no it's an anime where they go
into a vr world like the metaverse and
then they have to fight monsters and the
guy who created it is like now that i
have you if you die in the game you die
in real life and you can't log out yeah
kind of thing like traps everybody in
the universe interesting yeah that's
nuts people are trapped
bitsu says beliefs of corporate
dissidents ian it's facebook tim it's
the metaverse luke it's the umbrella
corporation
pretty much the umbrella corporation
kurt sutter says let's not forget if
elon chooses or is forced to sell stock
in his company for whatever reason
control of his company is slowly
transferred to someone else taxation
equals loss of control that's correct
lethal five six
seventy says tim what about a flat tax
let's say 25 no deduction no loopholes
just a flat tax that everyone pays so i
think luke made a really good point
about you know taxes being bad in
general my my attitude is more just like
in the current version of the system it
doesn't work we should do it like a
different way the issue with the flat
tax is basically
poor people are negatively impacted by
even a light tax like if you're if
you're only gonna get 200 bucks for the
week and you need every penny
then they take out even 20 bucks that is
a kick in the balls yeah if you're rich
and you're expecting a million dollars
to come in in one month and they tell
you that and i'm talking profit like
income at the top and they say we're
taking 80 percent
sure it sucks but 200 000
to spend money on bro i assure you that
person's gonna be like that's ridiculous
they're taking my eight hundred thousand
dollars
i don't even know what to spend any of
it on anyway to be honest yeah granted i
believe the person should be free to
choose how they want to allocate their
money my point is just that rich people
do not look at percentages the same way
poor people do a flat tax in my opinion
makes no sense they literally print
money out of thin air taxes are just the
way to control people that's like it's
it's how they effectively pay back what
they rip off it's how they steal money
from you
all right where are we at where are we
at
the great anywho says hey guys thanks
for the info keep it with the good work
luke google goldbacks
luke you know about goldberg oh yeah i
got a stack of them yep i got something
you saw right yeah gold gold foil bills
yep they're used a lot in new hampshire
with the free state project people
barter with them people trade with them
yeah they're worth i think like um in
gold like two and a half like 250 or
something i think but i think the actual
value of them because they're they're
they're coated and plastic is like four
bucks yeah something like that
yep i got a big stack because they're
cool it's a utah gold backs it's just
gold foil it's 1 1000th of a troy ounce
all right got a big old super chat jump
adam davidson says tim have you seen the
dr mccolo episode on jre i've seen parts
of it luke did you watch it i was
watching uh a large portion of it it was
a lot of truth bombs it was a major
major interview that
is making its rounds on the internet
right now and he said a lot of very
important things especially about
preventative treatments early treatments
and i think he really hit the nail on
the head with his perspective and his
findings so what you're saying is joe
rogan is far right
no he's definitely i don't think he is
he interviewed a doctor a medical
professional that was talking about his
findings that of course were the total
opposite of what dr fauci was saying
all right
american capitalists as i believe kelly
is running against lisa murkowski that's
correct
yeah i can't stand the uniparty you know
i'm really excited because i feel like
no matter what happens the uniparty is
out yeah you know that's kind of where i
think i think where we're going
just know more that establishment crony
trash it'll just be complaining about
aoc and you know what i mean
that's fine whatever
well she's actually still uniparty she
she jumped in the unit party as soon as
she gave she was given the chance is she
is she is she a trojan horse in the uta
party
i think i don't know about a trojan
horse i think she just willfully was
like i want to be in the unit party
she's ready to change some stuff didn't
she like audition for her role in
congress wasn't that i don't know about
that or was that a fake theory i don't
know i don't know if that's true
but you know whatever it's like if you
want to complain about someone's policy
position is fine but aoc is the worst
example a bad example because she's
she's very uniparty cutthroat
lies cheats steals all that stuff like i
don't mind you know progressives who
believe things i disagree with or who i
think might be dumb
adam schiff is like on a scale of you
know zero being you're really dumb and
you know 100 being you're a really good
person who's really smart and negative
100 being like you're pure evil vile
scum like adam schiff is a negative 100.
he's probably one of the worst human
beings i've ever seen
ever
doing anything
and i've seen some bad people
yeah as long as you're not trying to
censor us i'm happy for you to advocate
for whatever you want as long as it's in
you know an open forum that's
uh censorship resistant so
that that's the thing about schiff is
that he is trying to remove all of the
critics and the january 6 committee
that's exactly what it's for it's to
essentially in my opinion intimidate
people into
um not opposing them because you're
going to have problems if you do so i
think they should need a narrative for
the midterms they just need something to
say and it's like it's how they can keep
trump alive like trump's not here he's
not in the midterms and they're like
what can we do to say trump again that's
their plan man
tom penny says y'all pick on people with
blue hair a lot i have blue hair ian is
great luke thanks for coming back
lydia's base tim's all right and then a
winky face thanks dude what is that
supposed to mean
he's cool for having blue hair the
chronicles of chris says tim look up the
story of the second renaissance from
animatrix human humans chose the fate
they met
yeah i gotta be honest like in the
matrix
philosophically what were the humans
fighting for they were fighting for
autonomy right they didn't want to be in
the matrix but the machines weren't
mistreating the humans
they didn't want to be slaves to the
matrix they didn't seem to mind going
into it
this is a crazy idea right
that these people were slaves to the
matrix to the machines to be used as
power but
the reality was so awful and like you'd
eat white sludge for food and like you'd
be miserable and awful but i think the
reality is freedom is for the individual
and the individual has a right to choose
and the problem was the machines took
away their right from birth
so you don't get to take people and tell
them i'm going to make your life better
as a justification for stripping them of
their rights wasn't there also another
dude who was plugging himself into the
matrix so he could enjoy trivial no that
was the bad guy that was cypher he was
trying he was trying he did that he sold
them out to get injected back in the
matrix but i think there was someone
else um i think there was a short scene
where someone was enjoying something
like helicopter writing i forgot
uh we should rewatch the whole well
they could plug themselves into their
own programs yeah and like you could
create programs where you could do
really crazy fun things just like the
metaverse
yeah it could be metaverse propaganda
very often throughout history there's
been the excuse that stripping people of
their rights has been good for them you
know what i mean and some sometimes it's
been objectively true like
uh or i should say in the instance of
the matrix it was objectively true
that's shipping a person of their rights
in the matrix they are living a
comfortable life in the 1990s where they
could eat food and have steak but in the
real world the world was destroyed so
they're objectively better off in the
matrix except
you don't have a right to take someone's
rights away the machines do not have a
right
to to take that choice from them if
people were born and then told here's
the world and here's the matrix what
would you prefer that's a different
story
if people had the right to choose i'd
rather live in the matrix and they say
what we're going to do we're going to
why are you why are you up you're going
to be fed recycled nutrients from other
corpses when they age out and other
organic matter but you're going to get
to live in a normal real like like a
like an old reality where you'll
flourish and straw and thrive and do
your own thing
otherwise you can live in the underbelly
of the decaying dead earth eating sludge
i don't know what would you guys pick
i like uh i like the underdogs i'll
probably be eating sludge and i take
this machine robots i take the sludge
because you could always plug yourself
into your own private program
you know what i mean yeah so it's like i
don't know why they didn't do that
i know the cypher guy was like i want to
be back in the matrix it's like bro you
can literally just plug yourself in in
the ship yeah and then go anywhere you
want and do whatever you want like why
would you want to be back in the matrix
i don't know they don't cook my steak
the right way
your life also has meaning and value
when you're fighting for something if
you're just given everything that you
ever wish for it's valueless
right we need conflict
we need something yeah all right let's
do one more here
chance justice says
why not a flat 25 sales tax and no
income tax poor can save by not spending
rich pay more for luxuries and there
would be no need for irs agreed we'll do
it that way
no taxes i don't want taxes i stop
giving the government money they
mishandle it and they give it to their
friends that's true i don't understand
like yeah they're going to give it to
amazon they're going to give it to
google to build
and facebook to build the metaverses and
control every aspect of your existence
no
okay let the free market speak let's
let's have some competition to these
monopolies out there for frick's sakes
yeah the issue with the fiat system is
that we're you know we're basically
powerless in it and we're still kind of
rearranging the chairs on the titanic
because ultimately you know if we're
talking about monetary policy we're
talking about the us dollar which we
have really no influence upon so it's
really just kind of a really class
system which is of course you know why i
like bitcoin so much but um in terms of
taxation uh i just you know i keep going
back to i just rather have an exit ramp
yeah what do you mean an exit ramp i'd
rather just decouple the federal
government entirely from the economy
and you cannot do that through
uh reorienting the u.s dollar because
the u.s dollar will always be controlled
by the ruling class so
eventually you're going to have to
i mean it's kind of like you know a loop
and cap position but the the reality is
that i think the economy would be much
healthier if the state had zero control
over the economy damn right all right
everybody
go to timcast.com become a member we're
gonna have a members-only segment coming
up we're gonna talk a lot about the uh
we're gonna talk about a lot of the
covid stuff that youtube does not does
not want us to talk about
so uh greatly appreciate that everyone
has been uh hanging out becoming a
member smash that like button subscribe
to this channel uh what what am i
missing here subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends go to
teamcast.com follow us at tim cast irl
basically everywhere you can follow me
at tim cast and if you are willing to go
that extra step go to amazon and search
for tales from the inverted world and
pick up your copy of tim cast books i
don't think we're actually calling it
that but we've we've got our first book
being published it's a series of stories
on ghosts simulation theory
uh and serial killers now this is just
the first volume and we're already
working on the next violent this book is
275 pages i'm so excited for this stuff
the next book we're going to be working
on hopefully we'll we'll maybe be ready
in maybe six months or so as ghosts of
the civil war
conspiracies missing gold
old crazy war ghost stories ufos is this
is nuts we're already getting and then i
think the next one after that is going
to be the chicago mafia ghost stories
exploring what was going on the
conspiracies and murder so that's really
really it's going to be a lot of fun
stuff so again smash that like button on
your way out subscribe to this channel
uh jordan you want to shout anything out
yeah if you want to see more of my work
you can check it out at
dossier.sac.com it's awesome that you
have a publishing house that's the way
to go self-publish
techn i guess sure
so uh yeah if you guys want to hear me
speak more goodly
and more of my luke bonix you can
because i just released two videos today
one on luke uncensored.com and another
one on youtube.com forward slash we are
change i always strive to provide you
the information that could help people
the most and um
it's great to have some of you guys a
part of my audience i appreciate being
here and it's always a lot of fun i love
that shirt it really pops thank you it
does coming at me well you got to spread
the freedom yeah yeah literally uh it's
coming uh it's coming at me hey guys
thanks for coming ian crossland check me
out eating cross on the net jordan i
wanted to it's ian crossland.net and
jordan i want to shout out your twitter
uh it's jordan shakhtal
yeah yeah thanks shaq tail is how you
pronounce it correct thanks man thanks
for coming good thanks for having me
guys that was good
yeah thank you for coming jordan thank
you guys everybody for tuning in tonight
you guys are all more than welcome to
follow me at sourpatchlids on twitter
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com where you can become a
member and get access to a massive
library of members only content and help
support our journalists so again smash
that like button on your way out and
we'll see you all there bye guys
you